WANT TO WELCOME EVERYONE TO THE
WEDNESDAY APRIL TENTH TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN MEETING OF THE
ASSEMBLY HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE.
OBVIOUS IT THIS TIME WE DO NOT
HAVE ENOUGH MEMBERS PRESENT TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM SOME GONNA
ASK FOR ALL MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMITTEE IF YOU COULD PLEASE
JOIN US IN ROOM ONE TWENTY SIX
BUT GIVEN HOW MANY ITEMS WE HAVE
AND HOW MANY MEMBERS ARE RUNNING
AROUND TO DIFFERENT.
COMMITTEES I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN
IN THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE AND WITH THAT MR
BLOOM IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO JOIN
US AT THE DíAS.
I KNOW YOU HAVE TO ITEMS -- LINE
ITEM SEVEN AND EIGHT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO TAKE LINE ITEM SEVEN
FIRST.
WHICH IS -- TWELVE SEVENTY NINE
GOT IT IT'S UP TO YOU WHICHEVER
ONE YOU WANT TO DO BUT THAT'S
THE FIRST IN OUR SEVENTY NINE IN
MY HAND TO THE TWELVE SEVENTY
NINE FILE ITEM.
SEVEN SO THANK YOU AND GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR REMOVING
LAND USE BARRIERS TO EQUITABLE
AND INCLUSIVE DEVELOPMENT AND
HIGH RESOURCE AREAS OF THE STATE.
PLACES WITH GOOD SCHOOLS JOBS
ETCETERA IS AN ESSENTIAL PART OF
ADDRESSING CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING
CRISIS AND INCREASING CHOICE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR LOW INCOME
FAMILIES.
MANY OF THE PLACES WITH THE MOST
X. A X..
MOST EXISTING RESOURCES AND
AMENITIES REMAIN INACCESSIBLE TO
LOW INCOME PEOPLE AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR.
AND THESE OF THE LACK OF DENSE
MULTI FAMILY HOUSING IS ONE OF
THE MANY BARRIERS THAT IMPEDE
THIS ACCESS.
HI RESOURCE AREAS MAY OR MAY NOT
BE NEAR EXISTING HIGH QUALITY
TRANSIT BUT THEY CAN SUPPORT
GREEN INFILL DEVELOPMENT WHICH
IS CRUCIAL TO SUPPORTING FUTURE
TRANSIT EXPANSION.
IF WE ARE SERIOUS ABOUT
ADDRESSING THE STATE'S HOUSING
NEEDS IN REDUCING AUTO
DEPENDENCE THEN WE'RE GOING TO
NEED TO INCREASE DENSITY AND
EXPAND INFILL DEVELOPMENT IN
MORE.
PARTS OF THE STATE.
AB TWELVE SEVENTY NINE WOULD USE
DATA AND MAPPING TO IDENTIFY
HIGH RESOURCE AREAS WHERE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT IS
PREDOMINANTLY LOW DENSITY AND IT
WOULD SCREEN OUT PLACES THERE
ARE HIGH THAT ARE AT HIGH RISK.
FOR GENTRIFICATION AND
DISPLACEMENT THE REMAINING AREAS
AREAS WHERE THERE ARE STRONG
INDICATORS OF EXCLUSIONARY LAND
USE PATTERNS WOULD BE SUBJECT IS
OWNING OVER RIGHTS TO ENCOURAGE
THE PRODUCTION.
OF DANCE SMALL SCALE MARKET RATE
HOUSING AND LARGER SCALE MIXED
INCOME AND AFFORDABLE MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS WE
NEED TO BUILD BOTH A WE NEED TO
BOTH BUILD MORE HOUSING AND WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERY
CITY IS DOING THEIR FAIR SHARE.
TO PROVIDE A RANGE OF HOUSING
TYPES AT A RANGE OF INCOME
LEVELS.
EVEN PLACES THAT HAVE
TRADITIONALLY FROWNED UPON
DENSITY THANK YOU AND BY
WITNESSES SAID THAT ARE HERE
TODAY ARE ON YOUR LAWLER WITH
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND BRIAN AUGUSTA WITH
THE CALIFORNIA.
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION.
YOUR WITNESSES.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBER OF UNTIL OR WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY.
THIS BILL IS REALLY TARGETED THE
MOST HIGHLY EXCLUSIONARY
JURISDICTIONS IN THE STATE THOSE
THAT HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL AT
MAINTAINING LOW.
RESIDENTIAL DENSITY PATTERNS
MOSTLY SINGLE FAMILY IN
PROVIDING VERY FEW OPPORTUNITIES
FOR LOWER WAGE WORKERS TO LIVE --
THESE ARE COMMUNITIES THAT
EMPLOYEE LOWER WAGE WORKERS --
BUT THOSE WORKERS CANNOT LIVE IN
THE COMMUNITIES IN WHICH THEY
WORK BECAUSE THERE IS NO DANCE
MULTI FAMILY OR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING -- THE BILL ALLOWS FOR
THE DEVELOPMENT OF BOTH MARKET
RATE HOUSING AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND GIVE THE LAKE UP TO
THOSE AFFORDABLE PROJECTS
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT THOSE
PROJECTS ARE GONNA HAVE THE MOST
DIFFICULT TIME COMPETING FOR
LAND IN THESE COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE THEY DO TEND TO BE.
HIGHER INCOME AND THAT'S THE
LAND IS ALSO MORE EXPENSIVE SO --
WE THINK IT'S A REGIONAL
APPROACH TO GET MORE NEEDED
HOUSING IN THE PLACES WHERE IT
IS LACKING -- AND WOULD ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
GOOD MORNING TURN MEMBERS BY A
GUEST -- WITH CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION --
ECHO THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE JUST.
NOTE THAT WE THINK THIS WILL BE
AN IMPORTANT COMPLEMENT TO SOME
THE OTHER TOOLS THAT ARE BEING
DISCUSSED THIS YEAR.
IN BOTH HOUSES TO IN INCREASED
PRODUCTION AND PARTICULARLY HELP
INCREASE PRODUCTION OF HOUSING.
FOR THOSE MOST IN NEED OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND FOR THOSE
REASONS WE WOULD URGE AND I'VE
OUT.
THANK YOU LET ME ASK IF THERE
ARE OTHER SUPPORTERS OF THIS
MEASURE.
I WE ARE CO SPONSORS OF THIS
BILL I THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR
AND HIS STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
US AND WE ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANKS.
TYRONE BUCKLEY HOUSING
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT.
LET ME ASK IF THERE'S OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL.
LET'S BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY.
QUESTIONS.
I JUST WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR SUPPORTING NEW HOUSING
VERTICALLY AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
HI RESOURCE AREAS -- THIS IS A
BILL THAT I THINK WOULD PROVIDE
MORE FOLKS WITH THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT THEY WANT
PARTICULARLY FROM LOWER INCOME.
COMMUNITIES AND FROM COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR THAT HAVE BEEN
SYSTEMATICALLY EXCLUDED FROM
HIGH RESOURCE AREAS AND I AM
GONNA BE SUPPORTING THIS TODAY
AND LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING HOW
THE CONVERSATION GOES DURING THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
WE DO NOT YET HAVE A QUORUM SO
WE WILL HOLD THIS BILL.
FOR A MOTION UNTIL WE DO AND
WITHOUT -- MAYBE WILL EXCUSE US
HAVE YOU FOR THIS FILE ITEM AND
MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM.
EIGHT THANK YOU THAT'S A. B.
THIRTEEN NINETY NINE MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBER -- THE ELLIS ACT
ALLOWS LANDLORDS TO EXIT -- THE
BUSINESS OF OF RENTING GUIDE --
TO TENANTS -- HOWEVER SOME
LANDLORDS ARE TAKING ADVANTAGE
OF A PERCEIVED AMBIGUITY IN THE
LAW BY DRIVING.
A TENANTS OUT AND THEN RE
RENTING.
OF THE PROPERTY -- WHICH
CONTRAVENES THE INTENTION OF THE
ALICE ACT AS SOME LANDLORDS
BELIEVE THAT -- THERE'S A
LOOPHOLE THAT ALLOWS THEM TO RE
RENT UNITS THAT WERE VACANT AT
THE TIME OF THE WITHDRAWAL AT
ANY TIME WITHOUT HEARING TO THE
LAW'S RESTRICTIONS.
ON UNITS RETURNED TO THE MARKET
WITHIN CERTAIN TIME PERIODS.
AND TO ADDRESS SAID THIS ODD --
MY PROPOSED LEGISLATION WILL
CLARIFY THE ELSE ACT IN THE
FOLLOWING WAYS.
IF A LANDLORD WHO INTENDS TO GO
OUT OF THE RENTAL BUSINESS
PERMANENTLY -- THE BILL REQUIRES
THOSE LANDLORDS TO PERMANENTLY
GO OUT OF THE RENTAL BUSINESS.
AND THIS WILL HELP PREVENT THE
MORE EGREGIOUS ABUSES THAT
ENCOURAGE LANDLORDS TO EMPTY
ENTIRE BUILDINGS IN ORDER TO
EVADE RENT LIMITATIONS.
THIS WILL ALSO REDUCE THE
INCENTIVE FOR LANDLORDS -- TO TO
ALICE A PROPERTY AND THEN LET
MUCH NEEDED HOUSING UNITS LIE
FALLOW FOR MORE THAN FIVE YEARS
SIMPLY SIMPLY SO THAT THEY CAN
RE RENT THE UNITS AT MARKET
RATES.
IT WILL -- THE BILL WILL CLARIFY
THAT THE ACT PROHIBITS THE
RETURN TO THE RENTAL MARKET OF
LESS THAN ALL THE UNITS IN THE
SAME WAY THAT THE WITHDRAWAL OF
LESS THAN ALL THE UNITS IS
PROHIBITED.
IN OTHER WORDS ONCE ANY UNIT IS
RETURNED TO THE RENTAL MARKET
THE ENTIRE PROPERTY IS
CONSIDERED BACK ON THE RENTAL
MARKET FOR PURPOSES OF THE ACT.
FINALLY THE LAW -- WILL MAKE
EXPLICIT THAT THE PAYMENT OF A
PENALTY DOES NOT EXTINGUISH THE
LANDLORDS OBLIGATION TO COMPLY
WITH THE LAW.
I'M HAPPY TO REPORT THAT WE'VE
REACHED AN AGREEMENT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS ON AMENDMENTS THAT WE
WILL TAKE IN THE NEXT COMMITTEE.
AND THAT WERE CLOSE TO REACHING
AN AGREEMENT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION WHICH I
HOPE TO HAVE RESOLVED BY THE
NEXT HEARING IN A
PARENTHETICALLY.
I WOULD SAY THAT -- LAST YEAR
WHEN I CARRIED THIS BILL -- WE
HAD WORKED OUT TO AMENDMENTS
WITH THE APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
SO I THINK THERE'S A GOOD REASON
TO BE OPTIMISTIC THAT WE WILL
HAVE A FULL AGREEMENT WITH --
BOTH THE APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
AND THE REALTORS -- AS OF THE
NEXT HEARING -- THIS BILL GETS
TENANTS SOME SECURITY AND
KEEPING THEIR HOMES -- IN A TIME
WHEN HOMELESSNESS FOR OUR POOR
SENIORS DISABLED AND EVEN
WORKING CLASS IS A REALITY THAT
IS JUST A PAYCHECK OR RENT
INCREASE AWAY DUE TO LACK.
OF READILY AVAILABLE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING [inaudible]
YOUR WITNESSES.
GOOD MORNING OF MY NAME IS
ALLISON RING A DEPUTY CITY
ATTORNEY FOR THE CITY OF WEST
HOLLYWOOD -- UNFORTUNATELY WHAT
WE'RE SEEING AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
IS A GROWING BELIEF AMONG
LANDLORDS THAT THEY CAN EMPTY
THE BUILDING BY USING ELLIS AND
THEN CHERRY PICK WHICH UNITS TO
PUT BACK ON THE RENTAL MARKET
WHILE HOLDING BACK.
OTHERS -- THE INCENTIVE IS.
TO GET AS MANY TENANTS OUT OF
THE BUILDING BEFORE SERVING
ELLIS NOTICES BECAUSE OF THE
UNIT IS VACANT WHEN THE ELLIS
NOTICES SERVED THERE ARE NO RENT%
RESTRICTIONS ON THAT UNIT GOING
FORWARD.
SO SOME LANDLORDS ARE USING THAT
AMBIGUITY IN THE ELLIS ACT TO
GET RID OF AS MANY TENANTS AS
POSSIBLE THEN SERVE ELLIS NOTICE
ON THOSE TENANTS WHO STAY.
AND THE TENANTS WHO REMAIN ARE
TYPICALLY THOSE THAT ARE MOST
VULNERABLE TO HOMELESSNESS
THEY'RE THE ONES WHO HAVE BEEN
THERE THE LONGEST HOOVER PAYING
THE LOWEST RENT AND IT'S THOSE
TENANTS THAT ARE THE TARGET OF
THIS TACTIC.
AND SO ONCE THE ELLIS NOTICES
ARE SERVED IN THOSE TENANTS ARE
VICTIMS.
THE LANDLORD WILL THEN RE RENT
ONLY THOSE UNITS THAT ARE
WITHOUT RENT RESTRICTIONS
MISTAKENLY BELIEVING THAT THEY
CAN HAVE ONE FOOT IN THE RENTAL
MARKET AND ONE FOOT OUT.
THIS BILL WILL CLARIFY THAT
YOU'RE EITHER ON THE RENTAL
MARKET OR YOU'RE OFF TO PREVENT
THOSE KIND OF INCENDIARY TACTICS
WE WOULD -- DRIVE OUT THANK YOU.
NONE THANK YOU BYE HAVE BRIGHT
ACOSTA WITH THE SANTA MONICA
RENT CONTROL BOARD IN THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN.
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE I JUST
WANNA.
QUICKLY.
ADD THAT -- IN ANSWER THAT
SIMPLE -- SUMMARY OF THIS BILL
IS REALLY THAT WERE CLARIFYING
THE ORIGINAL INTENT OF THE ALICE
ACT I THINK -- BAD SIMPLE
CLARIFICATION.
THAT IS -- IS EVIDENCED BY WHERE
WE ARE WITH OUR DISCUSSIONS IN --
WITH INDUSTRY GROUPS WHICH IS
THAT WE'VE GOT THE REALTORS
OFTEN WORKING WITH CA WE THINK
IT'S CONSISTENT WITH THE
ORIGINAL INTENT OF THE ACT.
AS MS REGAN SAID YOU'RE EITHER
IN OR OUT THERE'S ONE THE WHOLE
BUILDING IS IN OR THE WHOLE
BUILDING IS OUT THAT'S ALL THIS
BILL.
IS INTENDED TO CLARIFY AND FOR
THOSE REASONS WE WOULD URGE IN
ABOUT.
LET ME ASK IF THERE ARE OTHER
SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL.
SHOP HER EXACT LOOK AT COMPOUND
AND ONE THANK US SERGEANT I'M
NOT SURE IF THE MICROPHONE IS ON
SOMEONE JUST.
DOUBLE CHECK THAT WELL LET ME
ASK NOW IF THERE'S OPPOSITION.
DEBORAH CURLED WITH A CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT CESSATION I WON'T SAID
BECAUSE I THINK WE'RE GOING TO
TRY TO FIND THE ANSWERS THAT WE
NEED.
IN THE AMENDMENT SO THANK YOU
FOR CONTINUING TO LET US TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR.
A GOOD MORNING -- MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS -- CREAM GREASY ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS -- IS
INTRODUCED A CA ARE DID HAVE AN
OPPOSE LIST MENDED POSITION ON
A. B..
THIRTEEN NINETY NINE IS THE BILL
WOULD HAVE SUBVERTED A LANDLORDS
LAWFUL ABILITY TO RETURN A
RENTAL PROPERTY TO THE MARKET.
SEE OUR HAS RECENTLY REACHED AN
AGREEMENT WITH THE AUTHOR IN THE
SPONSORING A MOMENT LANGUAGE --
THIS LANGUAGE WOULD REMOVE THE
WORD PERMANENTLY AS WELL AS MAKE
ONE OTHER MINOR CHANGE -- BASED
ON THE AUTHORS -- COMMITMENT TO
AMEND THE BILL SEE OURS NOW
NEUTRAL ON THE MEASURE -- NCR
WAS CERTAINLY LIKE TO THINK THE
AUTHOR HIS STAFF -- THE SPONSORS
AS WELL AS COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS ON THIS
MEASURE IN HELPING US TO RESOLVE
OUR CONCERNS.
AND WE CERTAINLY LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AS WELL
AS THE COMMITTEE ANOTHER
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS THE
SESSION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING SHERRY MEMBERS KATE
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA RENTAL
HOUSING ASSOCIATION WE TO HAVE
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL BUT
APPRECIATE AMENDMENTS LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING THEM IN PRINT
AND CONTENT.
THE OTHERS OFFICE THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER OPPOSITION.
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS.
I WANNA THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
YOUR DOG AT WORK ON THIS TOPIC --
I THINK WE ALL KNOW THIS IS A
VERY NARROWLY TAILORED BILL
REALLY TO ENSURE THAT -- THE
ELLIS ACT -- CONTINUES AS IT WAS
ORIGINALLY INTENDED REALLY
APPRECIATE BOTH SIDES IN THE
WORK YOU'VE DONE AND HOW CLOSE
YOU ARE -- I ACTUALLY SIT ON THE
NEXT COMMITTEE THAT THIS BILL IS
GOING TO GO TO UNDERSTAND WILL
GO TO ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY MY HOPE
IS.
AT THAT POINT THERE WILL BE A
GOOD RESOLUTION OF THIS BUT I
HAVE SUPPORTED THIS FROM THE
BEGINNING AND CERTAINLY NO WE
NEED TO KEEP CLARIFY THE ELLIS
ACT -- TO INSURE THAT TENANTS
ARE NOT EVICTED -- OUTSIDE OF
THAT I WILL BE SUPPORTING IT.
SO UNLESS OR ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
MR BUT WE WILL CONTINUE TO WAIT
FOR COR THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I WILL AT THIS TIME -- WITH THE
INDULGENCE OF MR GRAYSON MISTER
WICKER MISS WICKS I THINK WE
HAVE A VERY QUICK ITEM FOR MR
HOLDEN WHO'S BEEN WAITING
PATIENTLY -- FOR ALMOST A HALF
AN HOUR HERE SO WE WILL TAKE
THAT ITEM FILE ITEM.
THIRTEEN A. B. FOURTEEN NINETY
SEVEN ON HOSTING PLATFORMS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT ON A. B.
FOURTEEN NINETY SEVEN IT WILL.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE AND STAFF FOR THEIR
HARD WORK ON THIS BILL -- I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE
STAKEHOLDERS OF FOR COMING
TOGETHER -- AND WORKING WITH US
ON THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE AB
FOURTEEN NINETY SEVEN SUBJECTS.
PROPERTY ON A HOSTING PLATFORM
TO ANTI DISCRIMINATION LAWS
CURRENTLY THE DEPARTMENT OF FAIR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING HANDLES
DISCRIMINATION COMPLAINTS ON
HOSTING PLATFORMS.
AB FOURTEEN NINETY SEVEN WILL
CODIFY THE CURRENT PRACTICE AND
EMPOWER THE DEPARTMENT TO
CONTINUE INVESTIGATING AND
HANDLING THESE COMPLAINTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER ABOUT
[inaudible]
HE WITNESSES.
JOHN CALDWELL ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA HOTEL LODGING
ASSOCIATION CH LA BELIEVES
EVERYONE SHOULD HAVE EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY TO USE AND ENJOY
DWELLING WHICH IS WHY WE SUPPORT
THE BILL.
AND WITH THAT ANY OTHER
SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL.
ANY OPPOSITION THE BILL
[inaudible]
ANY QUESTIONS.
OUR THANK THE AUTHOR FOR A
MOVING FORWARD SOMETHING TO
CODIFY WHAT THE STATE HAS
ALREADY BEEN DOING AND
ADDRESSING DISCRIMINATION WHEN
IT COMES TO LODGING -- AND
HOUSING ACCOMMODATIONS I HOPE
THIS ISN'T EASY BILL FOR ALL OF
OUR MEMBERS TO SUPPORT AND I
WILL BE DOING SO TODAY.
WITH THAT THAT WAS PRETTY QUICK.
THANK YOU SIR.
AND WHAT WE CALL UP NEXT IN
ORDER MS WHISKS YOU HAVE I THINK
TWO ITEMS UP TODAY. NINE ELEVEN
SO FILE ITEM FIVE A. B. SEVEN
TWENTY FOUR FILE ITEM ELEVEN A.
B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY FIVE YOU WANT
TO START WITH FILE ITEM. FIVE
SEVEN TWENTY FOUR SEVEN TWENTY
FOUR FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
SO I THINK ALL OF US HAVE
EXPERIENCED IN OUR DISTRICT
ISSUES WITH -- RENTAL INCREASES
EVICTIONS HOMELESSNESS THE COST
OF LIVING BEING EXTRAORDINARILY
EXPENSIVE I KNOW IN MY DISTRICT
OF THE EAST BAY THE BEAUTIFUL
EAST BAY AS I LIKE TO REFER TO
IT.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE CHALLENGES
TEACHERS CAN AFFORD TO LIVE
THERE ANYMORE.
ON THEIR LIVING IN STOCKTON IN
TRACING COMMUTING TO OAKLAND AND
BERKELEY SO WE WE HEAR ABOUT
THESE ISSUES I KNOW ALL OF US
HERE ABOUT THIS IN OUR DISTRICTS.
AND WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE A
HOUSING CRISIS AND IT'S IT'S
REACHED ON PRESIDENT LEVELS THIS
IS A MID MAJOR SHE FOR THIS
LEGISLATURE IN A MAJOR ISSUE.
FOR THE GOVERNOR AS WELL.
WE DON'T HAVE IS CONFERENCE OF
STATEWIDE DATA. TO ACTUALLY LOOK
AT THE ISSUE AND HAVE A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING.
I'M FROM AN EMPIRICAL POINT OF
VIEW OF THE CHALLENGES THAT FACE
OUR COMMUNITIES AND YOU KNOW
WHAT ARE THE RENT INCREASES YOU
KNOW WHAT WHAT ARE WE SAYING ARE
WE SEEING TRENDS WE HAVE.
YOU KNOW.
YOU KNOW ZILLOW AND OTHERS ARE
ARE ARE GIVING SOME INFORMATION
THAT THAT EFFECT BUT THE THE
GOAL OF THIS BILLS TO REALLY
CREATE A STATEWIDE RENTAL.
REGISTRY SO WE CAN GET THAT DATA
FROM LANDLORDS HAVE A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF A WHAT IS
FACING OUR COMMUNITIES.
I'VE SPENT TIME TALKING WITH
BOTH TENANTS RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS AS WELL AS THE
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION AND AND MY
LOCAL LANDLORDS IN MY DISTRICT --
ABOUT SOME OF THESE ISSUES AND
FRANKLY YOU KNOW IN TALKING TO
MY LOCAL LANDLORDS THEY ARE ALSO
HUNGRY FOR THIS DATA AS WELL --
AS OUR OUR TENANTS AND SO THAT
IS WHAT A FUNDAMENTALLY THIS
BILL WILL DO IT WILL CREATE A
STATEWIDE RENTAL REGISTRY
THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT. TO ANNUALLY COLLECT
THE DATA ON RENTAL UNIT
INCREASES TENTATIVE ACTIONS AND
UNIT VACANCIES FROM LANDLORDS
AND PROPERTY OWNERS.
I AM COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
THE APARTMENT ASSOCIATION -- TO
TO FIGURE OUT A SOLUTION TO THE
PROBLEM -- AND WITH ME TO
TESTIFY HERE IS KATHARINE BREEZY
FROM TECH EQUITY -- I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANKS FOR OUR FOR HAVING ME --
I'M CATHY BRACEY I FOUNDED AND
DIRECT THE TECH EQUITY
COLLABORATIVE WHICH IS AN
ORGANIZATION BASED IN THE BAY
AREA -- THAT BELIEVES THAT THE
STATE'S TECH DRIVEN ECONOMY CAN
AND SHOULD CREATE BROAD BASED
OPPORTUNITY FOR MORE PEOPLE --
OUR CORE MEMBERSHIP CONSISTS OF
RANK AND FILE TECH WORKERS WHO
WANT TO USE THEIR UNIQUE POWER
AS RESIDENTS OF THE STATE TO
PUSH FOR POLICY CHANGES THAT
WILL.
ALLOW THE BENEFITS THAT ARE
INDUSTRIES CREATING -- TO CREATE
A MORE PEOPLE AND OF COURSE
SOLVING HOUSING CRISIS IS
OBVIOUSLY A CRITICAL ELEMENT OF
THAT EQUATION -- AS TECH WORKERS
WE ARE ACUTELY AWARE OF THE
IMPACT WE'RE HAVING ON HOUSING
COSTS IN CALIFORNIA WE ALSO FEEL
THAT CRISIS AS MANY OF US PAY
MORE THAN WELL MORE THAN A THIRD
OF OUR INCOMES AND FOR HOUSING --
WE KNOW THAT THIS IS
PARTICULARLY UNSUSTAINABLE FOR
OUR NEIGHBORS WHO ARE NURSES
TEACHERS BUS DRIVERS.
JANITORS AND OTHERS TO DO THE
CRITICAL WORK THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES NEED TO THRIVE.
AND FOR OUR NEIGHBORS HAVE BEEN
MADE HOMELESS OR BEEN DISPLACED
OUT OF THE REGION BECAUSE OF THE
LACK OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING -- AS
TECH WORKERS WE ALSO UNDERSTAND
THE IMPORTANCE OF HAVING A
RELIABLE DATA TO INFORM DECISION
MAKING AND OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS OF WE AS WE HAVE BEGUN TO
ENGAGE IN HOUSING ADVOCACY WORK
WE HAVE FOUND THAT THE POLICY
CONVERSATION AROUND TEN A
PROTECTIONS IN PARTICULAR -- IS
TAKING PLACE IN THE ABSENCE OF
REAL DATA ABOUT THE EXTENT OF
THE PROBLEM -- THE TRUTH IS NO
ONE REALLY KNOWS HOW MUCH RENTS
ARE INCREASING ACROSS THE STATE
THE THE DATA THAT DOES EXIST
FROM PLACES LIKE THE AMERICAN
COMMUNITY SURVEY OR COMPANIES
LIKE ZILLOW -- ARE INSUFFICIENT
IN MANY WAYS THEIR PROPRIETARY
THEY'RE EXPENSIVE THEY AREN'T
COMPREHENSIVE AND THEY TEND TO
REPORT SORT OF TOP LINE DATA
SUCH AS AVERAGES.
IN ORDER TO MAKE SMART HOUSING
POLICY WE NEED GRANULAR
TRANSPARENT AND COMPREHENSIVE
DATA ABOUT RENTAL PRICES THAT
CAN ONLY BE GATHERED BY ASKING
LANDLORDS TO SUBMIT THAT DATA
DIRECTLY.
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO STAND WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS ON THIS
BILL AND ARE URGING ALL OF YOU
TO SUPPORT WITH AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
AND AND JUST TO ADD ON TO THAT
AS WELL IF I COULD CHAIRMAN --
YOU KNOW THE GOAL OF THIS IS TO
HAVE -- AND CREATE EVIDENCE
BASED POLICY BASED ON DATA AND
THERE ARE SOME CITIES THAT DO
HAVE RENTAL REGISTRIES LOS
ANGELES FRESNO -- AND OTHERS BUT
THIS WOULD BE A STATEWIDE SYSTEM
THAT WE COULD -- YOU SO
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE TECH EQUITY
AND OTHERS THE TURNER CENTER
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS TENDS
GROUP'S LANDLORD ORGANIZATIONS
WILL HAVE THE DATA THEY NEED.
THANK YOU LET'S GO TO OTHER
SUPPORTERS.
ON A LAWLER WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
SUPPORT.
HE LUIS MONTI WITH CALIFORNIA
MEANS TRANSPORT.
IF YOU'RE MEMBERS RAND MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BUT NOW WE HEAR FROM ANY
OPPOSITION.
HI GOOD MORNING AGAIN MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS -- CREAM GREASY
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS -- IS
INTRODUCED US HERE HAD AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION ON AB --
SEVEN TWENTY FOUR AS THE BILL
WOULD HAVE IMPOSED ON OUR
STANDARDS ON SMALL LANDLORDS.
SEE OURS RECENTLY REACHED A
CONCEPTUAL AGREEMENT WITH THE
AUTHOR REGARDING AMENDMENTS --
THIS AMENDMENT WOULD EXEMPT
SMALL LANDLORDS WHO OWN OR
MANAGE.
RESIDENTIAL REAL PROPERTY WITH
FIFTEEN UNITS ARE LESS FROM THE
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL -- BASED
ON THE OTHERS COMMITMENT TO
AMEND THE BILL SEE OURS NO
NEUTRAL ON THE MEASURE AND SEE I
WOULD CERTAINLY LIKE TO THINK
THE AUTHOR HER STAFF -- AS WELL
AS THE SPONSOR AND COMMITTEE
COMMITTEE STAFF -- FOR THEIR
WORK WITH US -- TELL THIS CAN
RESOLVE OUR CONCERNS ON THIS
MEASURE -- WE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE IT -- WE HAVE SENT A
MOCK UP OF THE AMENDMENT TO THE
AUTHORS OFFICE AND THE COMMITTEE
STAFF AND WE CERTAINLY LOOK
FORWARD -- TO WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE -- ON FINALIZING THAT
AMENDMENT LANGUAGE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
AT DEVER CARL TO THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION I THINK WE
WOULD ARGUE THAT THE SOLUTIONS
NOT A DATABASE BUT NOW IT'S
GOING TO TAKE OUT 75% OF THE
RENTAL HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA
IT'S NO LONGER STATEWIDE
DATABASE -- BUT IT'S REALLY
ABOUT IT SHOULD BE ABOUT A
DATABASE OF ABOUT BUILDING
HOUSING AND WE'VE ARGUED FOR THE
IMPORTANCE OF FINDING AND
BUILDING MORE HOUSING SO THAT
OUR TEACHERS CAN LIVE CLOSE.
I'M OUR CONCERN OF COURSE IS THE
BIG PRIVACY INVASION NOT ONLY
FOR RENTAL PROPERTY OWNERS BUT
FOR TENANTS A LIGHT THEIR
NEIGHBORS ARE GONNA NOW NO.
THEY'VE GONE FOR WHAT REASON
PERHAPS IT IS A FICTION PERHAPS
THAT INFORMATION IS ALREADY
MASKED IN THE COURTS.
WE DON'T WANT TO AT LEAST EXPOSE
ALL OF THAT INFORMATION PLUS IF
YOU ENDED UP WITH SIX MILLION
RENTAL UNITS IN THIS SYSTEM IN A
MATTER OF NINETY DAYS.
I WOULD SAY THAT'S AN EXPENSIVE
A PROPOSITION THAT DOESN'T
REALLY PROVIDE US ANY KIND OF
SOLUTIONS THAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR
SO TODAY WE'RE ASKING FOR YOUR
NO VOTE.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS PAT RIGHT
WITH THEIR AND READING
ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA RENTAL
HOUSING ASSOCIATION WE
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS THAT --
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER TOOK WHAT
THE TAKE THAT BACK -- TO OUR
CLIENT HAVE THEM LOOK AT THAT TO
SEE THAT ALL ALTER THEIR
POSITION ON THE BILL -- WE DO
KNOW THERE'S ONE AMENDMENT THAT
SHE COULD TAKE THAT WOULD REMOVE
OUR OPPOSITION COMPLETELY IS THE
SHE EXEMPTED -- SIX OWNERS WITH
SIXTEEN OR MORE UNITS BUT THAT'S
PROBABLY NOT HAPPEN.
IN LIGHT OF THAT WE ARE WE ARE
WE AS WE REMAIN OPPOSED TO THE
BILL BUT WE'LL TAKE A LOOK AT
THE AMENDMENTS AND SEE IF THAT
CHANGES A POSITION THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING SURE MEMBERS KATE
ON THE CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION WE'RE ALSO GOING TO
REVIEW THE AMENDMENTS TAKE A
DOCTOR MEMBERSHIP -- BUT WE ARE
CONCERNED WITH THE BILL BECAUSE
OF THE SHARING OF PRIVATE
INFORMATION AND ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDEN SO THEREFORE OPPOSED
THANK YOU.
LET'S BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS
MISTER MAIENSCHEIN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
I I APPRECIATE ALL THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT I'VE HAD WITH
THE AUTHOR I KNOW YOU'VE WORKED
VERY HARD ON THIS -- IN I
DEFINITELY UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO -- I KNOW
IT'S STILL A WORK IN PROGRESS I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMITMENT TO
CONTINUE -- WORKING WITH -- THAT
THE PARTIES INVOLVED THE
AMENDMENT -- TO EXCLUDE
PROPERTIES AT PROPERTY SMALLER
FIFTEEN YEARS SO IT WAS GOOD
BECAUSE IT.
KINDA GETS TO THOSE MOM AND POP --
ONCE A MIGHT HAVE A HARDER TIME
COMPLYING JUST -- FROM A LACK OF
A BAND WITH ISSUE I WANT TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY -- COULD
BECAUSE I APPRECIATE YOUR HARD
WORK AND I APPRECIATE YOUR A
COMMITMENT TO KEEP -- THE
CONVERSATION MOVING.
MY HOPE BY THE TIME IT'S A FOR
SOME OF THESE OTHER ISSUES CAN
BE WORKED OUT BUT HAPPY TO
SUPPORT IT TODAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS MR YEP.
OF THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
GUESS HAVE A QUESTION -- FOR OF
THIS WAS CALLED IN A OUR WITNESS
OF DEBORAH YOU YOU MENTIONED
THAT THE AMENDMENT WILL TAKE
AWAY WHAT 75% OF OF WHAT.
CAN YOU CLARIFY THAT THE SIXTEEN
IF IF THE AUTHOR ACCEPTS THE
AMENDMENTS FOR SIXTEEN OR FOR
YOUR UNITS THAT IS THE BULK.
OF RENTAL HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA.
SO WE BELIEVE THAT THAT'S NOT
GOING TO GIVE THE AUTHOR THE
STATEWIDE DATABASE THAT SHE
WANTS NOT THAT WE WOULD SUPPORT
IF SHE HAD A BACK IN.
SECOND I CAN'T.
BUT I DON'T THINK IT
ACCOMPLISHES WE HAVE ARGUED THAT
THERE'S ALREADY PLENTY OF DATA
OUT THERE -- ON PUBLIC WEBSITES
ON THE SENSES THE DATA THAT YOU
CAN ALREADY CLEAN THAT THE
COURTS ALREADY HAVE AN EVICTION
SYSTEM.
A REPORTING SYSTEM IN WHICH YOU
COULD GET EVICTION INFORMATION
AS WELL SO WORK REQUIRING WHAT
WAS ONCE SIX MILLION UNITS TO BE
TO COME INTO A SYSTEM.
IS REALLY -- NOT NECESSARY I
THINK WE GET THE DATA OTHER
PLACES IN A MORE ECONOMICAL WAY.
I'M NOT SURE WE HAVE CORM YET
BUT I I AND AND THE SHERIN I WAS
SAID ABOUT THE THE AUTHOR THIS
BILL HAS.
HAS HAD MULTIPLE CONVERSATION
WITH ME ON IT OF COURSE WE STILL
HAVE SOME CONCERNS -- I WILL --
NOT BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
TODAY BUT I DO LOOK FORWARD --
TO SUPPORTING ON THE FLOOR IF
SHE'S ABLE TO REACH SOME SORT OF
AGREEMENT -- WITH THE OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
GREAT -- MS WHICH HAVE A COMMENT
WE WANTED TO ADDRESS THE PRIVACY
ISSUE.
PLEASE YEAH I WOULD SAY THAT
WERE ALSO VERY COMMITTED TO
PRIVACY INDIVIDUAL PRIVACY WE'VE
AGREED TO ADOPT AN AMENDMENT --
THAT WOULD MAKE SURE THAT THIS --
DATABASE CAN -- COMPLIES WITH
ALL STATE LAWS -- ON ON IN TERMS
OF PRIVACY -- AND TO BE CLEAR
THE DATA THAT WE WOULD BE
SUGGESTING THAT WE'RE COLLECTING
IS NOT SPECIFIC TO INDIVIDUALS
AT SPECIFIC TWO APARTMENT UNITS --
WE DON'T NEED THE ACTUAL ADDRESS
LIKE UNIT NUMBER OF THE
APARTMENT WE JUST NEED TO KNOW
UNIQUELY YOU KNOW IF THERE ARE.
TWENTY UNITS IN THIS -- BUILDING
UNIT ONE THROUGH TWENTY HAS X.
NUMBER OF BEDROOMS AND THE RENT
IS X. -- AMOUNTS AND HAS CHANGED
YEAR OVER YEAR I DON'T THINK
THAT THAT WOULD VIOLATE THE
PRIVACY OF OF ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
LIVES IN THAT BUILDING OR THE OR
THE LANDLORD FOR THAT MATTER.
I JUST WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR MOVING THIS IMPORTANT TOPIC
FORD WOW WE ALL KNOW THAT
RENTERS AND TENANTS ARE IN THE
MOST.
INTENSE CRISIS THAT THEY HAVE
BEEN IN OUR STATE'S HISTORY AND
WE'RE HAVING MANY DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT DIFFERENT IDEAS OF HOW TO
ADDRESS THE CRISIS -- AND I
THINK WE WOULD ALL AGREE ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE EQUATION THAT
HAVING DATA HAVING FAX WOULD
BETTER INFORM THIS.
UP ONE THING I I I DO UNDERSTAND
FROM THE OPPOSITION THAT YOU
BELIEVE THERE ARE OTHER SOURCES
FOR US TO RECEIVE THIS DATA.
I HAVE TO ADMIT THATI HAVEN'T
SEEN THEM AND SO IF YOU WANT TO
PROVIDE US WITH THAT DATA AND
INFORMATION I WOULD WE LOVE TO
SEE WHATEVER YOU FEEL LIKE WE
CAN CLEAN -- BUT SINCE WE
HAVEN'T SEEN THAT I THINK WE
HAVE TO MOVE FORWARD WITH SOME
SORT OF DATA COLLECTION BILL.
I WANT TO THANK -- THE COMPANY'S
DECISION REALTORS FOR YOUR WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR I WOULD HAVE
PREFERRED THIS TO BE A LOWER
THRESHOLD -- AND CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND THAT IT IS GOING --
TO IT MEAN THAT WE WILL HAVE
LESS DATA BUT I THINK HAVING
SOME DATA IS BETTER THAN HAVING
NO DATA AND WITH THAT -- GLAD
THERE WAS AN UNDERSTANDING AND
HOW WE MOVE THIS FORWARD -- THIS
ITEM THE SENATE MOVES OUT OF
THIS COMMITTEE WILL MOVE TO THE
ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE ON
WHICH I ALSO SET SO I'M SURE
THIS CONVERSATION WILL CONTINUE.
WITH THE OPPOSITION BUT ACTUALLY
LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE JUST
ESTABLISH A QUORUM SO.
LET ME JUST -- IN MY COMMENTS
AND IF THERE'S NO OTHER
QUESTIONS ASK THE AUTHOR IF YOU
HAVE ANYTHING YOU LIKE TO SAY IN
CLOSING SURE I WOULD JUST WANT
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
MEMBERS ON THIS COMMITTEE -- THE
OPPOSITION AND THE STAKEHOLDERS
OF THE SPONSORS OF THIS BILL TO
GET THIS BILL TO A PLACE WHERE
WE CAN ALL VOTE FOR ON THE FLOOR --
AND I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE IN THIS COMMITTEE
TO MOVE THIS BILL FORWARD.
GREAT THANK YOU WE NOW HAVE
QUORUM SO MADAM SECRETARY COULD
YOU PLEASE ESTABLISH
[inaudible] EIGHT GABRIEL
[inaudible]
GLORIA.
KILEY.
LEE MON.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MENTION HERE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA HERE THANK YOU.
HERE.
AND IS OUR MOTION TO MOVE THIS
BILL FORD.
THEIR SECOND.
SECOND UP MADAM SECRETARY COULD
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY. TWO HI I
DEEP ARE VOTING.
GABRIELLE.
GABRIEL I GLORIA.
KILEY LEE MON MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN NIGHT QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE.
SO -- YOU NEED A FEW MORE VOTES --
WILL STILL WAIT FOR DISH MEMBERS
I JUST WANNA CLARIFY THIS IS TO
PASS TO THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS WILL BE TAKEN AS
AUTHOR MEMBERS OF THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND WHAT WE MOVE TO YOUR NEXT
ITEM FILE ITEM ELEVEN AB
.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY FIVE THE CO.
TWO I WANT TO AGAIN THANK THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE -- FOR
HAVING ME HERE TODAY -- AS I'VE
EXPLAINS PREVIOUSLY MY LAST BILL
WE ARE IN A HOUSING CRISIS I
THINK THAT'S PROBABLY ONE OF THE
MOST COMMONLY REFERRED TO ISSUES
THAT YOU'LL HEAR -- IN THIS BODY --
CURRENTLY NOW -- THE THE
GOVERNOR HAS SAID WE NEED TO
BUILD THREE POINT FIVE MILLION
HOMES -- AS WE KNOW BUILDING
HOMES HAS BEEN A CHALLENGE -- IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA BUT IT
IS CRITICAL WE NEED TO BUILD
HOMES AT ALL INCOME LEVELS HERE --
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
WE'VE TAKEN CERTAINLY -- MANY ON
THIS COMMITTEE AND OTHERS WHO
COME BEFORE ME IS I AM A
FRESHMAN HERE -- HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE FOR A LONG
TIME AND OF PUT FORTH VERY
THOUGHTFUL POLICIES TO TRY TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO THAT WE CAN
IN FACT BILL MORE HOME SEVENTY
TWO IN OUR COMMUNITY.
AND IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN GOVERNOR
BROWN SIGNED SB THIRTY FIVE
SENATOR SCOTT WINNERS BILL --
INTO LAW TO STREAMLINE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS
PROVIDING ON SITE AFFORDABILITY.
HOWEVER SB THIRTY FIVE HAS ONLY
BEEN EFFECTIVE FOR PRODUCING
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS IN A VERY
SPECIFIC INCOME CATEGORY.
MY BILL AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY FIVE
WILL EXPAND EXISTING
STREAMLINING LAWS TO ENCOURAGE
MIXED INCOME HOUSING PRODUCTION --
FOR MODERATE INCOME HOUSING IN
THE NINE COUNTY BAY AREA IS THE
NINE COUNTIES IN THE BAY AREA --
IS WHAT THIS BILL WOULDN'T WHAT
IMPACT -- HERE TO TESTIFY WITH
ME IS A MATT REGAN FROM THE BAY
AREA COUNCIL -- AND MICHAEL LANE
IT AS VIçT HOME AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
MISTER REAGAN THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR -- I MATT READING WITH THE
BAY AREA COUNCIL WE ARE A
BUSINESS SPOSORED PUBLIC POLICY
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION.
OUR MEMBERSHIPS COMPRISES ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY OF THE
LARGEST EMPLOYERS IN THE BAY
AREA.
OUR NUMBER ONE ISSUE OF CONCERN
IS -- THE AFFORDABILITY CRISIS
IN OUR REGION IT HAS -- AND WENT
A BIT TO BORE YOUR BILL LABOR
YOU'VE HEARD IT MANY TIMES I'M
SURE BUT WE ARE.
PERHAPS THE MOST EXPENSIVE
REGION IN THE NATION I THINK
SEVENTEEN OF THE TOP TWENTY
RENTAL MARKETS IN THE UNITED
STATES ARE IN OUR REGION -- IT'S
A PLACE WHERE -- NONE BUT THE
VERY WEALTHIEST COULD AFFORD TO
LIVE AND THAT'S A PROBLEM FOR
ALL OF OUR MEMBERS -- AVERAGE
RENTS IN SAN FRANCISCO RIGHT NOW
FOR A ONE BEDROOM OR NORTH OF
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS A DOOR IN
THE REGION AS A WHOLE IT'S
BETWEEN TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS AND THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
AVERAGE CONSTRUCTION COSTS AND
SAN FRANCISCO ARE ABOUT SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A UNIT -- FOR THE REGION
IT'S OVER SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS A UNIT -- WE'RE SEEING
COST INFLATION FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION OF HOUSING AT ABOUT
10% A YEAR -- AND WE DON'T HAVE
A TOOL REALLY AVAILABLE TO US TO
ADDRESS WHAT WE CALL THE DONUT
HOLE THE MISSING MIDDLE
WORKFORCE HAS -- THERE'S
OBVIOUSLY SOME FUNDING AVAILABLE
FOR SUBSIDIZED BELOW MARKET RATE
HOUSING OBVIOUSLY NOT ENOUGH BUT
SOME SO THERE'S SOME ACTIVITY
THERE.
THE MARKET CAN AFFORD TO BUILD
FOR NONE BUT THE WEALTHIEST AND
THE DONUT HOLE IN THE MIDDLE --
OUR TEACHERS ARE CHILD CARE
WORKERS. TWO TWO INCOME FAMILIES --
COULD NOT AFFORD TO LIVE IN THE
BAY AREA A FAMILY OF TWO
TEACHERS -- DOESN'T QUALIFY IN
MOST OF OUR REGION FOR
SUBSIDIZED HOUSING AND CAN'T
AFFORD MARKET RATE HOUSING.
THIS BILL PROVIDES A VERY SIMPLE
TOOL TO INCENTIVIZE BUILDERS OF
HOMES -- TO BUILD MARKET RATE OF
MARKET RATE HOUSING FOR THE
MISSING MIDDLE PROVIDES IN THE
CENTER AN INCENTIVE FOR THEM TO
BUILD A PRODUCT THE TWO TEACHERS
CAN CAN AFFORD SO I ARCHER I
**** THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS CHURCH IN MEMBERS A
MICHAEL A MUSCLE KIND BELLY AT
HOME.
HOUSING ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
REPRESENT THE SENATE SANTA CLARA
COUNTY -- AS NOTED THERE COUPLE
POLICY POINTERS ONE EMPHASIZED
IS A SUMMER WORK SAID THIS IS
REALLY ORIGINAL BILL FOCUSED ON
THE HIGH COST AND FRANCISCO BAY
AREA AS A PILOT -- AND THE GOAL
OF COURSE TO PROVIDE HOUSING FOR
THOSE WHO MAKE WHO WEREN'T TOO
MUCH. TO BE ABLE TO ACCESS
SUBSIDIZE AFFORDABLE HOUSING BUT
NOT ENOUGH REALLY TO COMPETE IN
THE MARKET FOR HIGHER UP PRICE
MARKET RATE UNITS TO TRY TO
CREATE A NEW BELOW MARKET RATE
IS WE BELOW MARKET RATE UNITS.
WITHOUT HAVING TO USE STATE AND
LOCAL SUBSIDIES AND THAT'S THE
OTHER KEY POINT THE REASON THAT
WE'RE REALLY HERE.
IN PARTICULAR IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILLS WERE SEEN A MOVEMENT AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL AT THE STATE
MORE PRESSURE TO DIVERT.
FINITE AND PRECIOUS AFFORDABLE
HOUSING RESOURCE DIPPED OF
HOUSEHOLDS OF HIGHER AND HIGHER
INCOMES.
AND WE REALLY TO TARGET THOSE
RESOURCES -- AT LOWER INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS FOR A 100% AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SO THE IDEAS CAN WE COME
UP WITH ANOTHER PROGRAM THAT
DOESN'T REQUIRE TO TREAT THOSE
THOSE THOSE FIGHTING PRESSURES.
RESOURCES TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
THIS BELOW MARKET RATE.
HOUSING AVAILABLE FOR THOSE WITH
HIGHER INCOMES IN THAT WE THINK
THAT'S A BETTER PUBLIC POLICY
APPROACH.
AND THAT'S THE REASON WE'RE HERE
FOR EXAMPLE SB TO OR FROM THE
SOURCE FUNDING.
DID ALLOCATE SOME FUNDING FOR
MIDDLE INCOME AND IS YOU KNOW
GOVERNOR NEWSOME IS ALSO
PROPOSED ALLOCATE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE STATE
BUDGET. TWO COUCHES HIS BIGGEST
INCOME PROGRAM WHICH GOES UP
210020%.
OF A IN MY SO WE THINK THOSE
EFFORTS ARE FINE BUT THERE WON'T
BE SUFFICIENT SUBSIDIES REALLY
TO MAKE HEM UP TO THAT HAVE A
LOT OF THE SCALE.
SO WE THINK A PROGRAM LIKE THIS
IS APPROPRIATE PARTICULARLY IN
IN HIGH CAN A HIGH COST AREA --
TO TRY THIS TO BE ABLE DELIVER
BELOW MARKET RATE UNITS WITHOUT
USING A SUB RESOURCES AND WE ARE
DRIVE OUT.
THANK YOU OTHER SUPPORTERS.
HOLLY FOR MANY WITH WHITE HOUSE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY EAST BAY
SILICON VALLEY IN SUPPORT.
KEEP THE ROW ENTERPRISE
COMMITTEE PARTNERS [inaudible]
OTHER SUPPORTERS.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION.
MICHELLE PERCENT WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATES -- WE HAVE NOT TAKEN A
FORMAL POSITION ON THIS BILL BUT
WE DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS
REGARDING THE EXPANSIONS TO SB.
THIRTY FIVE AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR
BEFORE THE NEXT COMMITTEE THANKS.
GREAT LET'S BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY DISCUSSION MR
DEBORAH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I JUST
WANTED TO COMPLEMENT THE AUTHOR
FOR HER FOCUS ON THIS ISSUE AND
AS YOUR WITNESS ADDRESSED I
THINK IT'S A REALLY SMART TO
THINK ABOUT HOW WE ADDRESS THE
MISSING THAT -- WHICH WE ALL
KNOW IS A REALLY IMPORTANT PIECE
OF THE PUZZLE WITHOUT IMPACTING
SUBSIDIES FOR LOW INCOME FOLKS I
THINK THIS IS GREAT POLICY IN
PLACE TO SUPPORT IT TODAY.
THANK YOU.
THERE'S A MOTION MOVE THE BILL
THERE'S A SECOND -- ONE THING
I'LL JUST SAY ONE ALSO THANK --
THE AUTHOR FOR THIS I KNOW --
INITIALLY YOU WOULD PROPOSE
SOMETHING THAT WAS -- A FAIRLY
COMPLICATED STRUCTURE THAT WAS
INITIALLY FOCUSED IN THE BAY
AREA AND I THINK THROUGH A LOT
OF GOOD WORK -- MOVING FOR TWO
AND SB THIRTY FIVE STRUCTURE
STREAMLINING IT A BIT -- TO
SOMETHING THAT -- I KNOW THERE'S
A LOT OF SUPPORT AROUND THE
STATE OF APPLIED STATEWIDE WHICH
IS WHAT THIS BILL NOW DOES MAKES
A LOT OF SENSE AND I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THAT -- UNLESS
THERE'S ANY OTHER DISCUSSION LET
ME ASK IF YOU HAVE ANY FINAL
COMMENTS -- I JUST FOR POINT OF
THIRTY IN A WE TOOK THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS -- ERRORS
INTENT OUR INTENT IS TO KEEP
WORKING WITH COMMITTEE TO MAKE
SURE THIS IS -- A QUALITY
PRODUCT THAT WE CAN WE CAN MOVE
ON AND VOTE ON THE FLOOR AND
MAKE IT A VERY SPECIFIC BILL.
LOOK FOR TO THAT DISCUSSION.
AND I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR IPHONE RATE THANK YOU WELL
LET ME JUST BE CLEAR T'S A
STATEWIDE BILL AT THIS POINT WE
HAD YES.
ABOUT WE ARE ON THAT GREAT
NARROWING ITS FOCUS OKAY.
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AND A
SECOND MADAM SECRETARY.
MOTION TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
COMEDIAN LOCAL GOVERNMENT CHIU
HI I DEEP I I GABRIEL GABRIEL I
GLORIA.
GLORIA I KILEY LEE MON
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN NINE
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE.
YOUR BILLS OUT BUT FORTY FOR THE
CONVERSATIONS KEEP ME -- TOO
LET'S GO TO MISTER COREY SAN.
YOU FILE ITEM TEN AB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE DOES THIS
YEAR'S.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR GOOD
MORNING AND TO ALSO OF MEMBERS I
AM PLEASED TO PRESENT TO YOU
ASSEMBLY BILL.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR ATTENTION TO THIS BILL AND
NOTE THAT I WILL BE ACCEPTING
THE AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. TOO MUCH OF
THE HOUSING DATA COLLECTED AT
THE STATE REGIONAL AND LOCAL
LEVEL IS NOT ACCESSIBLE
STANDARDIZED OR ORGANIZED IN A
MANNER THAT LEVERAGES OUR
EXTENSIVE COMMUNITY OF HOUSING
RESEARCHERS AND ADVOCATES.
AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE WILL DO
THE FOLLOWING REQUIRE EIGHT CD
TO DEVELOP AND COORDINATE A
STATEWIDE PARCEL DATABASE THAT
WILL PROVIDE AN OPEN AND
FLEXIBLE FRAMEWORK FOR
ORGANIZING THE STATE'S HOUSING
DATA.
REQUIRE CITIES AND COUNTIES TO
TRANSPARENTLY PUBLISH A VARIETY
OF HOUSING DEVELOPMENT PIPELINE
DATA INCLUDING FEES APPLICABLES
TO HOUSING DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS
AND INFORMATION RELEVANT TO THE
PER -- PRESERVATION OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND THE
PROTECTION OF TENANTS AND
HOMEOWNERS REQUIRE CITIES AND
COUNTIES TO REPORT ANNUALLY ON
INFORMATION THAT WILL HELP US.
TO UNDERSTAND THE PROGRESS THEY
ARE MAKING ON APPROVING HOUSING
INCLUDING THE NUMBER OF
DISCRETIONARY PERMITS BUILDING
PERMITS AS A TRAFFIC IT'S OF
OCCUPANCY ISSUED.
FINALLY THE BILL WILL REQUIRE A
CD TO DEVELOP A TENURE DATA
STRATEGY IN THAT STATE HOUSING
PLAN TO ENSURE THAT ALL FUTURE
DATA REQUIREMENTS.
ARE COORDINATED AND THAT
JURISDICTION'S ARE SUPPORTED IN
THEIR ROLES.
I AM PLEASED TO BE WORKING WITH
THE AMERICAN PLANNING
ASSOCIATION AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS ON OUR SPECIFIC
DATA REQUEST TO BE SURE THAT WE
ARE FOCUSED.
ON INFORMATION THAT IS READILY
AVAILABLE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AND
DIRECTLY PERTINENT TO HOUSING
POLICY MAKING AND REGULATORY
ENFORCEMENT.
AND INVESTMENT IN OUR DATA
CAPACITY WILL NOT ONLY RESULT IN
MORE EFFECTIVE BEFORE
ENFORCEMENT OF EXISTING HOUSING
POLICIES BUT IT WILL DRIVE
BETTER DECISION MAKING AS WE
CONTINUE TO SEARCH FOR SOLUTIONS.
TO OUR HOUSING AFFORDABILITY
CRISIS MY WITNESSES TODAY OR
MICHAEL GUNNING WITH C. B. I ATE
AND MARINO WYANT FROM THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING SOCIAL
[inaudible]
YOUR WITNESSES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN --
MICHAEL GUNNING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION WE'RE UP WE SOME
PROUD TODAY TO SPONSOR AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE A BILL
THAT WOULD PROVIDE VALUABLE
INFORMATION ABOUT FEES SPECIAL
TAXES AND PROPERTY ASSESSMENTS
ASSOCIATED WITH HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS.
BY POSTING THIS INFORMATION
PUBLICLY ACADEMICS CAN STUDY THE
CORRELATION BETWEEN FEES TAXES
AND HOMEBUILDING.
CITIES CAN COMPARE THEIR FEES
AND HOMEBUILDING. TO THEIR PEERS
ELECTED OFFICIALS CAN MAKE MORE
INFORMED DECISIONS AND A
DISCUSSION ABOUT HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION CAN FINALLY BE HAD
BASED UPON CLEAR DATA.
IN ESSENCE WE THINK AB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY THREE WILL HELP.
COLE A VALUABLE DATA IN ORDER TO
BRING CLARITY TO HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION AND THE ASSOCIATED
FEES AND PROPERTY ASSESSMENTS
AND I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MARINO WHITE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CONSORTIUM -- AS POLICY
MAKERS AND ELECTED OFFICIALS
CONTINUE TO LOOK FOR WAYS TO
ADDRESS THE HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS -- IT'S AN
IMPORTANT THAT WE DO IT IN A WAY
THAT ACTUALLY ADDRESSES THE
ISSUES WERE TRYING TO SOLVE AND
THEY WERE DOING IN A CAREFUL
THOUGHTFUL WAY -- WITHOUT
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES AND THIS
BILL REALLY HELPS US DO THAT AND
FOR THAT REASON WE'RE REALLY
PROUD TO THE CO SPONSOR.
THANK YOU.
OTHER SUPPORTERS.
JENNIFER SPEC A MAP THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT.
MORNING ADAM REGULAR BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN SUPPORT THANKS.
FEDERAL GOLF ALL BEHALF OF THE
NONPROFIT HOUSING ASSOCIATION
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
KEEP THE ROUTE WITH ENTERPRISE
CAN BE PARTNERS IN IN SUPPORT.
PROVOCATEUR GUESS REPRESENTING
LEADING AGE CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT.
MICHAEL IN MUSCLE COME DAILY AT
HOME IN SUPPORT.
HI FOR MANY LIGHT HOUSE PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF A HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
MALLORY SOCCER WITH CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
MATT REGION WITH THE BAY AREA
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
ME ASK IF THERE'S ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE ANY COMMENTS
QUESTIONS.
I JUST WANT TO THANK THE CHURCH
THE AUTHOR FOR MOVING THIS
FORWARD WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS BILL FOR
MANY MANY MONTHS AND THIS IS A
BILL CERTAINLY IN THE CATEGORY
OF UP MORE DATA MORE FACTS IS
GOING TO HELP US SOLVE THE
CRISIS.
AND I'M HAPPY BECAUSE OF THIS
BILL AND ENJOY -- HOPEFULLY
MOVING THIS OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND MOVING IT TO THE
PROCESS.
THERE'S A MOTION AND A SECOND IF
THERE ARE NO OTHER FINAL
COMMENTS WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NINE OKAY
MADAM SECRETARY.
MOTION TO PASS IS AMENDED TO THE
COMEDIAN LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
CHIU HI CHIU HI DAVE.
HI I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I GLORIA GLORIA I KILEY.
LEE MONTH.
THE MONTH I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN NINE QUIRK SILVA.
KIRKSVILLE BY [inaudible]
RIGHT.
YOUR BILL IS OUT WE'LL WAIT FOR
OTHER MEMBERS TO ADD ON OCT
COLLEAGUES WILL WE HAVE A LITTLE
BIT OF TIME WAITING FOR OTHER
AUTHORS -- WE HAD A NUMBER OF
MEMBERS WHO PRESENTED AND I LIKE
TO JUST -- DO SOME ADD ONS AND
ALSO MAKES A MOTIONS. SEVEN
SEVEN SO -- MISTER BLOOM WAS
FIRST PRESENT WE DO NOT HAVE A
QUORUM AT THAT TIME SO LET ME
ASK IF THERE'S A MOTION FOR FILE
ITEM SEVEN A. B..
TWELVE SEVENTY NINE OUR MOTION
WITH THIS ITEM FORTY PHYLUM.
SEVEN IS OUR SECOND.
OKAY MA'AM SECRETARY COULD
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AND FILE
ITEM SEVEN AB.
TWELVE SEVENTY NINE MOTION TO
PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. TWO FIVE TWO HI DAVE.
NO THE NO.
GABRIEL GABRIEL I GLORIA.
GLORIA I KILEY.
LEE.
ONE LIMóN I'M SORRY --
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN BYLER SEVEN SEVEN
TOLD.
OKAY AND QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA HI WITH ANOTHER
AUTHOR HERE SO WHEN WE TAKE UP.
MR CHAN'S ITEM AT FILE ITEM NINE
AB.
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
I'M HERE TODAY PERCENT AB.
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN WHICH IS A
DISTRICT BILL THAT WILL HELP THE
CITY BRAND REFER TAX DOLLARS
BACK TO THEIR PARAMEDIC PROGRAM.
THERE ARE MANY LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS SPECIAL DISTRICTS
THAT PASSED VOTER APPROVED LOCAL
TAXES THE FUND PARAMEDIC
PROGRAMS.
THAT ARE RUN THROUGH THEIR FIRE
DEPARTMENTS IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT THE VOTERS AND BRAD PROVED
A PARAMEDIC TAX TO FUND.
PARAMEDIC SERVICES IN THE CITY
THE INTENT OF THE TAXES TO
FINANCE LOCAL PARAMEDIC PROGRAMS
BUT WHEN REDEVELOPMENT WAS
CREATED A PORTION THE PARAMEDIC
TAX WAS CAPTURED BY THE
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY.
AND THIS DIVERSION REMAINS IN
EFFECT TODAY.
AB FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN WILL
RESTORE ON PERCENT OF THE
PARAMEDIC TAX THE FUND THE
PARAMEDIC PROGRAM AND THEREBY
FULLY IMPLEMENT THE ORIGINAL
PURPOSE ATTACKS AS APPROVED BY
THE VOTERS.
YES GENERAL OBLIGATIONS WILL BE
PAID FOR FROM OTHER IF THEY WILL
TAX REVENUE RESOURCES FROM THE
CITY OF VERA THERE FOR THE
PARAMEDIC TAX TO BE ALLOCATED
FOR THE PURPOSE INTENDED BY THE
VOTERS. FOR A PARAMEDIC PROGRAM.
THERE HAVE BEEN A FEW BILLS THAT
THE LEGISLATURE HAS ADOPTED IN
THE PAST TO DEAL WITH A SIMILAR
VOTED APPROVE TAXES.
AND THIS BILL WILL ADD PERMITTED
PROGRAMS THAT LIST HERE TO HELP
JUSTIFY WITH MEAN AND ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS IS COUNCIL MEMBERS
CITY HELP OF BREA.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN CHIU AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M BEFORE I
STARTED LIKE TO TELL YOU A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT OUR CITY.
BREA IS A SMALL COMMUNITY WERE.
TWELVE TWELVE POINT FOUR SQUARE
MILES NESTLED IN THE HILLS OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WE BORDER
UNINCORPORATED ORANGE COUNTY.
RIVERSIDE COUNTY -- BUT HAVE ANY
COUNTY AND LA COUNTY -- WHEN
THIS BILL WAS VOTED INTO PLACE
WE WERE?
A CITY OF ABOUT EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND PEOPLE WE'RE NOW CITY
OF FORTY FOUR THOUSAND PEOPLE
BUT OUR DAYTIME POPULATION GOES
TO OVER A HUNDRED AND TWENTY WE
HAVE A NUMBER OF BIG BUSINESSES
WE ARE AN AGING COMMUNITY AND
OUR PARAMEDIC SERVICES ARE.
THE MAJORITY OF OUR CALLS.
WE CURRENTLY SUPPLEMENT OUR
PARAMEDICS SERVICE WITH ABOUT
ONE POINT FOUR MILLION FROM OUR
GENERAL FUND.
SO IF WE CAN TAKE THE MONEY
THAT'S BEING USED TOWARDS THE
REDEVELOPMENT OBLIGATIONS.
THAT WAS ORIGINALLY INTENDED TO
PAY FOR PARAMEDIC SERVICES WE
COULD RECOVER QUITE A BIT OF OUR
OUTPUT -- AND THE STAFF HAS
ASSURED ME WE'VE LOOKED AT THE
NUMBERS THE REMAINING TAX
INCREMENTS IS MORE THAN
SUFFICIENT TO PAY THAT
OBLIGATION.
SO THIS WOULD JUST MAKE OUR
COMMUNITY HALL.
SO I WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER.
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC THE WISH TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION.
WE BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE A
DISCUSSION.
HIS OUR SECOND. ONE THANK THE
AUTHOR I KNOW THAT THIS IS A
BILL THAT ADDRESSES -- AN ISSUE
IN YOUR DISTRICT -- AND WE HAVE
ADDRESSED SIMILAR ISSUES FOR
OTHER TYPES OF PASSED THROUGH
TAXES.
AND SO -- I THINK IT IS
APPROPRIATE THAT WE SUPPORT THIS
TODAY -- AND LESS THERE ANY
FURTHER COMMENTS WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER JERRY'S ROUGH
LAST RIDE.
RIGHT MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASSED THE COMEDIAN
LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
TO CHIU HI DAVE HI I GABRIELLE.
CABRIOLET I GLORIA.
GLORIA I KILEY.
LEE MONTH.
THE MONTH I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN NIGHT QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA HI.
YOUR ITEM IS OUT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND UP
ONE WE GO BACK TO ADDING ON I
THINK THERE MIGHT BE A LITTLE
CONFUSION AROUND MR BLOOM'S VOTE
SO WE CAN GO BACK TO FILE ITEM.
SEVEN OKAY SO THAT THE RECORD.
OKAY IF I COULD JUST SAY --
PHYLUM SEVEN ALREADY HAS FIVE
VOTE SO IT WILL GET OUT -- BUT I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THERE'S NO
CONFUSION AROUND BILLS.
SHE HAS A DIFFERENT TALLY
[inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
ON SIR WERE JUST CONFIRMING THE
VOTES.
GETTING HAVE.
ONE FORTY WE WENT TO ANOTHER AND
WE KNOW.
YES YOU JUST YES I'M GONNA ASK
SECRETARY TO MENTION THE
RECORDED VOTES BECAUSE WE HAVE A
LITTLE BIT OF A DISCREPANCY
MADAM SECRETARY COULD YOU.
TELL US WHAT WE HAVE ABSOLUTELY
CHU IS A NIGHT THE A NO.
A GABRIELLE AYE FLOREA I LEE MON
NINE BORING MAIENSCHEIN NINE
FORTY AND QUIRK SILVA I SO IT'S
FOUR TO ONE GET THE SENATE HAS
FOUR VOTES.
THIS IS ITEM SEVEN CORRECT
MISTER MIND CHANT MISSION.
MR MAN TRYING TO CHANGE HIS VOTE
TO YES SO IT NOW HAS FIVE VOTES
[inaudible]
OKAY -- ONE WE JUST CONTINUE
WHEN WE CONTINUE VOTING WHILE
WE'RE ON IT AND THEN WE WILL GO
TO MISTER NAZARIAN FILE ITEM
EIGHT AB THIRTEEN NINETY NINE IS
THERE A MOTION.
SECOND ARM.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THIS IS A BE.
THIRTEEN NINETY NINE MOTION IS
TO PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY TWO FIVE CHIU I DEEP
NO.
NO [inaudible]
GABRIELLE.
GABRIEL I GLORIA.
GLORIA I KILEY.
THE MON LAMONT I MAIENSCHEIN
[inaudible]
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA BY ONE CITY.
TRY THAT -- ITEM NOW HAS FIVE
VOTES -- AND SO THAT WILL MOVE
OUT WILL WAY FOR OTHER AT A
MEMBERS AND THEN.
I BELIEVE ONE OTHER ITEM WE DO
NOT HAVE A MOTION YET IS --
HOLDEN.
LET'S MOVE TO FILE ITEM THIRTEEN
AB FOURTEEN NINETY SEVEN HOLDEN
IS OUR MOTION.
AS OUR SECOND.
MADAM SECRETARY COULD YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL MOTION TO PASSED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
TO AYE CHIU AYE THE HI GIVE AYE
GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I GLORIA.
GLORIA I KILEY.
LIMA LIMA HI MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA I FIVE SIX SEVEN
ZERO THAT ITEM WILL GET OUT AND
WE WILL WAIT FOR ONE MORE AND ON
AND THEN IF WE GO BACK TO FILE
ITEM FIVE WHICH IS THE OTHER
ITEM THAT'S BEEN PRESENTED AB.
SEVEN TWENTY FOUR THERE'S
ALREADY BEEN A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE WE ADD ON
ANYONE WHO HAS NOT YET BEEN
ADDED ON ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA.
SUBMIT GLORIA I ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ELMONT.
NY MONTH I PLEASE.
THAT'S AT SIX ZERO MISTER KILEY.
WELCOME.
FILE ITEM FIVE HAS ENOUGH VOTES
TO GET OUT.
SIX ONE AND WITH THAT LET US NOW
GO BACK TO PRESENTATIONS MISTER
NAZARIAN FILE ITEM.
TO AB.
THREE NINETY THREE GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
AB THREE NINETY THREE REQUIRES
THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
STANDARDS COMMISSION TO ASSEMBLE
A WORKING GROUP CONSISTING OF
VARIOUS BUILDING HOUSING AND
ENGINEERING EXPERTS. TO
DETERMINE NEW POST EARTHQUAKE
BUILDING PERFORMANCE STANDARDS
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF ESSENTIAL
FACILITIES LIKE HOSPITALS AND
FIRE STATIONS CURRENT BUILDING
CODE IS ONLY DESIGNED TO PROTECT
AGAINST LOSS OF LIFE.
IF A MAJOR EARTHQUAKE HITS THE
CODE SAYS NOTHING ABOUT WHETHER
OR WHEN A BUILDING WILL BE EIGHT
UNABLE.
A USABLE AFTER A LARGE SEISMIC
EVENT.
EVEN NEW BUILDINGS ARE EXPECTED
TO HAVE SIGNIFICANT REPAIR COSTS
AND DOWNTIME AFTER A MAJOR
CALIFORNIA EARTHQUAKE.
PEOPLE WITH DISPLACED.
WOULD BE DISPLACED FROM THEIR
HOMES AND WOULD FACE A
SIGNIFICANT DISRUPTION TO THE
REGIONAL ECONOMY THIS BILL
DEFINES A FUNCTIONAL RECOVERY
STANDARD AS DESIGN CRITERIA.
AND REGULATIONS SUCH AS BUILDING
STRUCTURE ARCHITECTURE AND
SYSTEMS WOULD MAINTAIN THEIR
INTEGRITY OR COULD BE RESTORED
TO SUPPORT BASIC FUNCTIONS OF
THE BUILDING SPREE EARTHQUAKE
USE WITHIN A MAXIMUM ACCEPTABLE
TIME.
WHICH COULD DEPEND ON BUILDING
OCCUPANCY.
IT REQUIRES THE C. B. S. C. TO
CONVENE A WORKING GROUP TO
DETERMINE IF A FUNCTIONAL
RECOVERY BUILDING STANDARD IS
WARRANTED.
AND TO INVESTIGATE PRACTICAL
MEANS FOR IMPLEMENTING STANDARDS.
AB THREE NINETY THREE IS A STEP
TOWARD ENABLING CALIFORNIA TO
GET BACK TO NORMAL SOON AFTER A
LARGE EARTHQUAKE INSTEAD OF
HAVING BUILDINGS CLOSED. FOR
MONTHS OR YEARS AT A TIME WHICH
WE'VE EXPERIENCED IN MAJOR
CITIES IN OUR STATE.
I'M JOINED BY STRUCTURAL
ENGINEER RYAN CHRIS THING CHAIR
OF THE STRUCTURAL ENGINEERS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE ACTION COMMITTEE.
AND JOHN PARISH FORMER
CALIFORNIA STATE GEOLOGIST ON
BEHALF OF THE EARTHQUAKE
ENGINEERING RESEARCH INSTITUTE.
YOU'RE WITH US AS GREAT THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS FOR
THE OPPORTUNITIES GUS THE
IMPORTANCE OF AB THREE NINETY
THREE I'M RANCOR STING A
PRACTICING STRUCTURAL ENGINEER
HERE IN TOWN.
SACRAMENTO SPEAKING TODAY ON
BEHALF OF OUR THIRTY FIVE HUNTER
MEMBERS OF THE STRUCTURAL
ENGINEERS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA.
WHO ARE THE EXPERTS WHEN IT
COMES TO UNDERSTANDING THE
SEISMIC PERFORMANCE OF OUR
BUILDINGS?
THE SENTIMENT IS THERE AND GIVE
A GREAT SYNOPSIS OF THE BILL SO
I JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT A FEW
KEY POINTS.
UP FIRST WE ARE STRUCTURED
ENGINEERS KNOW THAT OUR BUILDING
CODES ARE FOCUS PRIMARILY IN
PROVIDING LIFE SAFETY WE ALSO
REALIZE THAT THE PUBLIC DOESN'T
UNDERSTAND THIS.
WE KNOW THAT THE PUBLIC -- AND
MANY OF YOU AND LOCAL LEADERS
HAVE START ASK US WHAT CAN WE DO
TO DO DIFFERENTLY OR BETTER
REGARDING THE RECOVERY ASPECTS
NOT JUST THE SAFETY ASPECTS OF
pOPPORTUNITY. TO RESPOND TO THAT
DESIRE AND INTEREST FOR
SOMETHING DIFFERENT OR BETTER IN
TERMS OF PERFORMANCE -- THIS
BILL EXPLORE INVOLVING OUR
BUILDING CODES PROTECT NOT JUST
LIFE SAFETY BUT OUR WAY OF LIFE.
BY CONSIDERING HOW WE CAN
RECOVER AFTER AN EARTHQUAKE. TO
THIS BILL DOES NOT MANDATE AN
IMMEDIATE CHANGE BUT RATHER
INITIATES THE PROCESS FOR KEY
STAKEHOLDERS.
FROM ACROSS ACROSS THE BUILDING
DESIGN AND CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY
TO DISCUSS.
HOW TO BETTER PROTECT
INDIVIDUALS AND OUR COMMUNITIES?
THE STATE'S ROLE IN THIS CAN BE
IN THIS GROUP IS REALLY
IMPORTANT WE NEED AND APPRECIATE
THE LEADERSHIP OF OUR ELECTED
OFFICIALS TO BRING CREDIBILITY.
FOCUS AND PRIORITY TO THESE
DISCUSSIONS.
THIRD THESE ACTIVITIES WILL BE
INFORMED BY AND WE'LL
COMPLIMENTS BUT NOT DUPLICATE
EFFORTS HAPPENING AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL.
C. OCAS AWARE OF ENGAGE IN THE
EFFORTS THAT THE KNEE HER
AGENCIES NESTON FEMA HAVE BEEN
TASKED WITH AND ARE ABOUT TO
BEGIN.
IN FACT ARE WORKING GROUP WILL
BE ORGANIZED RIGHT AS THE IT
WILL NOT BE A NEW STANDARD CODE
YET.
OUR AB THREE NINETY THREE
WORKING GROUP CAN DISCUSS HOW OR
IF THOSE OPTIONS MIGHT APPLY TO
CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE ALSO ENGAGED IN THE
SEPARATE -- CO DEVELOP A PROCESS
FOR THE NATIONAL MODEL CODE AS
WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
CODE.
AND THE TIMING OF OUR THREE
NINETY THREE WORKING GROUP IS
SUCH THAT OUR EFFORTS IN
CALIFORNIA COULD BECOME THE
BASIS FOR THE DISCUSSION AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL CALIFORNIA ONCE
AGAIN LEAD IN THE SEISMIC SAFETY
AND SEISMIC RECOVERY FOR OUR
COMMUNITY SIAC IS PROUD. TO
SPONSOR AND SUPPORT THIS
IMPORTANT BILL AND REQUEST AN
ENCOURAGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING UP MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ON JOHN
PARISH REPRESENTING THE
EARTHQUAKE ENGINEERING RESEARCH
INSTITUTE.
E. R. I. IS A NATIONAL NONPROFIT
TECHNICAL SOCIETY OF EXPERTS
DEDICATED TO REDUCING EARTHQUAKE
RISK IT'S MEMBERS INCLUDE
PROFESSIONALS -- IN A WIDE RANGE
OF SEISMIC SAFETY RELATED
SCIENTIFIC AND ENGINEERING
DISCIPLINES.
CALIFORNIA IS THE MOST
SEISMICALLY ACTIVE STATE IN THE
NATION OUTSIDE OF ALASKA.
HOWEVER BECAUSE OF THE STATE'S
VERY LARGE AND COMPLEX
INFRASTRUCTURE AND DYNAMIC
ECONOMY 66% OR THREE AND A
QUARTER BILLION DOLLARS.
OF THE NATION'S ANNUALIZED
EARTHQUAKE LOSSES ARE IN
CALIFORNIA.
BY COMPARISON ALASKA'S
ANNUALIZED EARTHQUAKE LOSSES
AMOUNT TO FORTY MILLION DOLLARS
WHICH IS LESS THAN THE LOSSES
SUFFERED BY CALIFORNIANS IN THE
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR NORTHRIDGE
EARTHQUAKE.
ABOUT TWO AND A HALF BILLION
DOLLARS OF CALIFORNIA'S
ANNUALIZED EARTHQUAKE LOSSES.
ARE CONCENTRATED IN THE GREATER
SAN FRANCISCO LOS ANGELES ORANGE
COUNTY AND SAN WERE TO DO YOU
KNOW COUNTY AREAS.
OVER THE PAST TWO HUNDRED YEARS
CALIFORNIA HAS EXPERIENCED
SEVENTY SEVEN EARTHQUAKES EQUAL
TO OR GREATER THAN THE MAGNITUDE
SIX WHICH IS A DAMAGING LEVEL.
LOOKED AT MORE CLOSELY -- THAT
BREAKS DOWN TO A DESTRUCTIVE
MAGNITUDE SIX EARTHQUAKE EVERY
TWO POINT EIGHT YEARS AND A
MAGNITUDE SEVEN EARTHQUAKE EVERY
ELEVEN YEARS.
ACCORDING TO THE UNIFORM
CALIFORNIA EARTHQUAKE RUPTURE
FORECAST THERE'S A 93% CHANCE OF
A MAGNITUDE SIX POINT SEVEN
NORTHRIDGE INTENSITY EARTHQUAKE
OCCURRING IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND A 97% CHANCE OF THAT
MAGNITUDE OCCURRING IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN THE NEXT THIRTY
YEARS. TO DATE THE CALIFORNIA
GEOLOGICAL SURVEY HAS PLACED
ZONES AROUND FIVE THOUSAND MILES
OF ACTIVE SERVICE FAULTS
AFFECTING THIRTY SIX COUNTIES
AND ONE HUNDRED FIVE CITIES.
FAR MORE THAN ANY OTHER STATE.
THESE ACTIVE FAULTS AFFECT
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
BUILDINGS.
IF CALIFORNIA WHICH OPERATES THE
WORLD'S FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY
AND EMPLOYEES AND SERVICES
NEARLY FORTY MILLION INHABITANTS
IS TO MAINTAIN AND GROW THAT
LEADERSHIP.
THAN CALIFORNIA WILL NEED TO
TAKE DECISIVE STEPS TO ENSURE
THAT THE RESILIENCY FROM THESE
EARTHQUAKE EVENTS.
WE THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
NECESSARY IN FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
ON THIS ISSUE AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LET ME ASK IF THERE ARE OTHER
SUPPORTERS.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION.
HIS OUR SECOND.
I WANT TO THANK MISTER NAZARIAN
FOR BEING REALLY I THINK IN OUR
LEGISLATURE THE CHAMPION FOR
SEISMIC SAFETY AND EARTHQUAKE
PREPAREDNESS AND VERY MUCH.
AS SOMEONE WHO HAS VOTED FOR
THIS BILL MULTIPLE TIMES HOPE
THIS IS THE YEAR THAT IT
ACTUALLY HAPPENS LET ME ASK IF
YOU HAVE ANY FINAL COMMENTS.
A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
OKAY MA'AM SECRETARY.
MOTION TO PASS TO THE COMEDIAN
APPROPRIATIONS TWO FIVE TWO I
DEEP AYE AYE GABRIELLE.
GABRIELLE I GLORIA.
GLORIA KILEY.
KILEY AYE LEE MOM [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN.
JOINT NIGHT QUIRK SILVA.
SILVER HI.
YOUR BILL IS OUT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU.
LET'S GO NOW TO MR CHOICE ITEM
FILE ITEM THREE AB.
FOUR FOUR SIX THE MONEY CHAIR
AND THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
TODAY I AM PRESENTING A. B..
FOUR FOUR SIX WHICH PROTECTS THE
VICTIMS OF ABUSE FROM --
DISCRIMINATION IN APPLYING FOR
HOUSING.
THIS BILL WAS INSPIRED OR DUE TO
TESTIMONY RECEIVED A LAST YEAR
FROM MANY VICTIMS SO ADVOCACY
GROUP. FOR THE ARE GROWING
ISSUES A SURROUNDING DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND THE DISCRIMINATION
TO THESE VICTIMS.
THIS IS A VICTIM ARE OFTEN NOT
VICTIMIZED OUT A SECOND TIME
WHEN THEY APPLY FOR HOUSING AND
THE FACE OF DOUBLE.
OR TRIPLE OR THE SECURITY
DEPOSITS.
INCREASES SO IN THE RENT.
OR ARE DENIED THAT THE
AVAILABILITY OF A UNITS SO ALL
TOGETHER.
ON THE APPLICANTS ARE
CHARACTERISTIC OF A BEING A
VICTIM ALL FIVE TYPE OF WHAT
ABUSE IS SO REALIZED.
VICTIMS OF ABUSE INCLUDE.
SURVIVAL SAW OF A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SEXUAL ASSAULT ELDER
WHAT DEPENDENT ABUSE.
HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND THE
STOCKING [inaudible]
ADVOCATES AND EXPOSE SO HAVE A
GIVEN DIRECT THE TESTIMONY TO
THE LEGISLATURE OVER THIS
UPGRADE FOR ISSUE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND THE IF IN THIS OP
COUNTY.
AND THE BRING TO THE LIGHT AND
THE NEED TO PROTECT THE VICTIMS
OF ABUSE.
OF FROM THIS SAW A BACON LEAH
UNFAIR DISCRIMINATION.
THE FIRST STEP UP TO OUR HERO
ANY VICTIM.
OF ABUSE IS SET TO ESTABLISH.
THE PERSON NOT IN A STABLE AND
THE STATE FOR LIVING ENVIRONMENT.
A HOME.
AND AB.
FOUR FOUR SIX ORDER TO PROMOTE
THE PAST A CHANCE OF FOR THAT TO
HAPPEN.
I'M CURRENTLY WORKING WITH THE
VICTIMS -- ADVOCACY GROUP.
ON THIS -- BILL AND IS --
IMPLEMENTATION.
AND OF FACILITATING TALKS SO
WITH YOU OR STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS
BILL -- TO ENSURE THAT THAT WE
APPROACH THIS ISSUE
RESPONSIBILITY AND EFFECTIVELY.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN PROTECTING OF
VICTIMS OF OF OF OF ABUSE OF
FROM HOUSING DISCRIMINATION.
AND THE HELP ENSURE THAT THAT
THE USE OF SURVIVOR SOCKS GIVEN
EVERY OPPORTUNITY. TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THEIR LIVES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHOI ARE THERE
ANY SPORTS OF THE BILL.
I DON'T HAVE A LOOKS LIKE YOU
HAVE.
SOMEONE.
NEVER CARL TO THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION WE'RE
WORKING WITH THE ASSEMBLYMAN TO
FIND A THE CORRECT WAY IN WHICH
WE WANT.
TO EXPLAIN WHAT GOES ON IN THESE
SITUATIONS AND THAT WERE
INSURING THAT WE HELP ALL
VICTIMS OF VIOLENCE SO -- I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING
WITH US AND WE WOULD RECOMMEND A
SUPPORT POSITION TODAY
[inaudible]
AND A GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS CREAM GREASY AND AFTER
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS -- HERE TODAY AS A
TWEENER JUST ECHO THE COMMENTS
MADE BY CA -- JUST WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR SINCERELY -- WE
DEFINITELY AGREE WITH THE GOAL
OF THE BILL AND WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR ON DRAFTING LANGUAGE AND
MAKING SURE IT.
WAS -- PLACED IN THE CODE
CORRECTLY SO THAT'S ONE THING
THE OTHER TO STAFF THE BEEN --
VERY APPROACHABLE AND VERY
AGREEABLE INTEREST THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU.
I'M SORRY I'M AT THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY -- WE
HAVE NOT TAKEN A POSITION ON THE
BILL BUT SIMILARLY STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE GOALS OF THE BILL
AND HAVE HAD REALLY PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS APPRECIATE THOSE
AND LOOK FORWARD TO RESOLVING
THE REMAINING ISSUES.
MORNING CUSTOMS LIKE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIPS AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE REALLY ONE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH HIS OFFICE
AND THE STAFF ON LANGUAGE IN
MOVING THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE
FORWARD.
THANK YOU I ARE THERE ANY
OPPONENTS TO THE BILL.
XENON BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR -- FOR MOVING FOR
PROTECTIONS FOR AN IMPORTANT BUT
OFTEN OVERLOOKED -- SUBSET OF
OUR COMMUNITY -- AND WITH THAT
YOU HAVE MY SUPPORT TODAY I DO
KNOW THIS BILL IS GOING TO GO TO
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WHERE WE
WILL.
TAKE ANOTHER LOOK AT OR I WILL
TAKE ANOTHER LOOK AT IT BUT
DOUBLY THING FROM HOUSING
STANDPOINT IT MAKES SENSE TO
MOVE THIS.
FOR ANY FOR THE DISCUSSION.
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION A SECOND
ANY FINAL COMMENTS.
RESPECTED AS WE ARE ABLE TO
MADAM SECRETARY.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMEDIAN JUDICIARY. TO HI CHIU
HI DAVE HI I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I GLORIA [inaudible]
KILEY.
KILEY I THE MON [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN.
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA I YOUR BILL IS OUT
WE WILL WAIT FOR OTHERS TO ADD
ON THANK YOU MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
MS FRIEDMAN.
YOU HAVE TO ITEMS FILE AND FOR
AN FILE ITEM -- SIXTEEN IF WE
CAN MAYBE TAKE THE FIRST ITEM
FILE ITEM FOR AB SIX SEVENTY ONE
YES GREAT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE AND THE CHAIR WORKING
WITH ME AND MY STOP ON THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION -- THIS
BILL IS INTENDED TO HELP SPUR
THE CREATION OF EIGHTY USE
ACROSS THE STATE IN PARTICULARLY
EIGHTY USE AS A SOLUTION TO THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS -- A
FINANCING INCENTIVES CAN BE USED
TO PROMOTE AFFORDABILITY AND
EIGHTY USE APPROACH FOR OWNERS
TO CONSTRUCT AND FOR TENANTS ON
AN ONGOING BASIS. FOR EXAMPLE AT
NAPA COUNTY OFFERS LOW COST
LOANS TO HOMEOWNERS TO CONSTRUCT
EIGHTY USE WHICH ARE THEN DEED
RESTRICTED TO BE AFFORDABLE TO
LOWER INCOME HOUSEHOLDS.
NON GOVERNMENTAL ENTITIES SUCH
AS THE HOUSING TRUST OF SILICON
VALLEY HAVE SIMILAR PROGRAMS.
IN LOS ANGELES THE CITY AND
COUNTY ARE WORKING TO CREATE
INCENTIVES FOR HOMEOWNERS SO
THAT EIGHTY USE CAN BE MORE
QUICKLY BUILT THROUGH SUBSIDIES
TO THE HOMEOWNERS WERE WILLING.
TO RENT THEIR UNITS TO HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS OR SECTION EIGHT
VOUCHER RECIPIENTS.
A LOT OF TIMES THE CREATION OF
EIGHTY USE AS A REAL WIN WIN FOR
THE COMMUNITY BECAUSE OF THE
THESE UNITS CAN BE CREATED AT A
MUCH LOWER COSTS THAN
TRADITIONAL AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
WHICH IN LOS ANGELES CAN BE SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS A UNIT
AND EIGHTY USE OF COURSE COST A
LOT LESS AND THEN YOU HAVE THE
PRIVATE HOMEOWNERS ALSO
CONTRIBUTING.
AB SIX SEVENTY ONE REQUIRES A
LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO INCLUDE A
PLAN IN THEIR HOUSING ELEMENT TO
INCENTIVIZE AND PROMOTE THE
CREATION OF EIGHTY USE THAT CAN
BE OFFERED AS A PORTABLE RENT
FOR VERY LOW LOW AND MODERATE
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS.
THE BILL REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT
OF HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT TO DEVELOP A LIST OF
EXISTING STATE GRANT AND
FINANCIAL INCENTIVES TO PROMOTE
PLANNING CONSTRUCTION AND
OPERATION OF EIGHTY USE.
AT AFFORDABLE RAMPS AND POSTED
ON THE DEPARTMENT'S WEBSITE.
SB SIX SEVENTY ONE CREATES A
WORKABLE RESOURCE FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION OF AFFORDABLE
EIGHTY USE OR THE HOMEOWNER
LOCAL AND STATE.
WITH ME TO SPEAK TODAY IN
SUPPORT IS DEBORAH CARLTON WITH
THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION AND I REQUEST FULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
MR HOUGHTON I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH YOU KNOW YOU JUST SAID IT
ALL IT.
I THINK WILL WIN THE LAST PIECES
HERE BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN WORKING
ON EIGHTY USE FOR THE LAST
DECADE OR SO WHEN WE'VE SEEN IN
HUGE INCREASE IN PERMITS AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL -- ALMOST TWO
THOUSAND IN LOS ANGELES -- OVER
A HUNDRED IN OAKLAND AND THIS IS
JUST IN THE LAST YEAR SINCE
WE'VE REALLY INCREASE THE
INCENTIVES FOR A TO USE.
THIS BILL WILL PUT I THINK ONE
OF THE AN IMPORTANT PIECE INTO
LAW AND THAT'S THE INCENTIVE
PIECE ESPECIALLY ON THE
FINANCING SIDE.
AND THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION FINDS THIS TO BE ONE
OF THE MOST CREATIVE AND COST
EFFECTIVE SOLUTIONS TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS.
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU LET ME ASK IF THERE
ARE OTHER SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL.
GOOD MORNING NUMBERS JENNIFER
SPEC COME OUT OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS WE HAVE
A SUPPORT OF AMENDED POSITION ON
THE BILL WE SUPPORT THE GOALS OF
APPELLANTS AND INCENTIVIZING
EIGHTY YOU DEVELOPMENT.
WHAT WE'RE WHAT WE'RE SEEKING IS
A REALLY A TECHNICAL FIX TO THE
BILL WERE HOPING TO CHANGE THE
PERCENTAGE -- OF AREA MEDIAN
INCOME FROM A HUNDRED AND 10%
TWO HUNDRED AND 20% TO BE
CONSISTENT WITH A VARIETY OF
OTHER PROGRAM SEEKING TO
INCREASE HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES
FOR MODERATE INCOME FAMILIES.
THANK YOU.
LET ME ASK IF THERE'S ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
THE MOVE THE BILL WAS CHAIRMAN
OKAY.
IT'S BEEN MOTION AND A SECOND
UNLESS THERE'S ANY DISCUSSION
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE UP.
MISS QUIRK SILVA.
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR I
KNOW THAT YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN IS
WORKING DILIGENTLY ON THIS IN
ESSENCE PACKAGE OF EIGHTY USE.
AND AYE NAMA JOINT AUTHOR ON AT
LEAST ONE OF THEM BUT I TOO HAVE
BECOME QUITE INTERESTED IN THIS
AREA AS THE CHAIR KNOWS WHEN WE
CAN BUILD ON EXISTING LAND -- WE
THEN PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY
WHETHER IT'S FOR INCENTIVES FOR
THE OCCUPANT ON TO TO HELP
SOMEBODY IN THE COMMUNITY OR IN
MANY CASES OF FAMILIES TO HELP
FAMILIES WHETHER IT'S THE OLD --
TERM GRANNY FLAT OR MOTHER IN
LAW WE KNOW THAT THAT MODEL IN
THE PAST HAS WORKED IN I MYSELF
I MYSELF WITH FOR MILLENNIALS
AND MY MOTHER WHO IN FACT IS.
IN OUR EIGHTY SO.
VERY MUCH -- I AM LOOKING
FORWARD TO SOME OF WHAT WE DO AS
A POTENTIAL FOR MYSELF IN THE
FUTURE -- BECAUSE OF COURSE WE
WANT TO KEEP OUR FAMILY'S CLOSE
AND SO ON SO THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN.
GREAT.
AND I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR MOVING THIS FOR WE'VE HAD A
NUMBER OF BILLS AROUND EIGHTY
YOU PRODUCTION BUT I CERTAINLY
THINK AS I'VE DISCUSSED WITH A
NUMBER OF FOLKS ON THIS
COMMITTEE.
THINK ABOUT HOW WE FINANCE
EIGHTY USES IMPORTANT AND I
THINK YOU HAVE COME ACROSS A
VERY CREATIVE WAY TO AND CENTER
LOCAL.
JURISDICTIONS -- TO PROACTIVELY.
MOVE FORTY DO YOU PRODUCTION SO
WITH THAT HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE
BILL.
THERE IS A MOTION SO WHY DON'T
WE UNLESS YOU HAVE A FINAL
COMMENTS.
I BELIEVE YOU DID SECOND.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
MISTREATMENT THIS I THINK THIS
IS A WAY TO REALLY BRING ARE
SINGLE FAMILY HOMEOWNERS -- INTO
BEING PART OF THE SOLUTION FOR
WHAT'S A STATEWIDE CRISIS AND A
LOT OF PEOPLE WOULDLOVE TO DO
EIGHTY USE AND HELP OUT BUT THEY
JUST NEED A LITTLE BIT OF HELP
AND THIS IS SUCH A COST
EFFECTIVE WAY. TO GREAT WAY FOR
THE STATE TO SPEND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DOLLARS -- FOR NOMINAL
FEES THAT CAN BRING NEW UNITS
ONLINE THEN GOES TO AFFORDABLE
PEOPLE I JUST THINK IT'S A VERY
ELEGANT SOLUTION I HOPE MORE I
HOPE A LOT OF LOCALITIES AND
BRACES.
GREAT THANK YOU.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
MOTION PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT TWO BY TWO
I THE I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I GLORIA [inaudible]
KILEY.
KILEY I LIMóN.
MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
QUIRK SILVA.
HI FOLKS HI.
YOU HAVE FIVE VOTES YOUR BILL
WILL GET OUT OF COMMITTEE WILL
WAIT FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON AND
NOW TO YOUR NEXT BILL FIGHT A
FILE ITEM SIXTEEN AB.
SEVENTEEN SEVENTEEN THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I'D LIKE
TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS ON THE BOTTOM OF PAGE.
NINE AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTEEN
CREATES A PROGRAM TO INCENTIVIZE
DENSITY AND CREATE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING UNITS IN TRANSPORTERS.
THE PROGRAM PROVIDES FUNDING TO
SUPPORT HIGHER DENSITY
DEVELOPMENT THAT WAS AND A HALF
MILE OF MAJOR TRANSIT STOPS AND
A QUARTER MILE A BUS SERVICE ON
LAND THAT IS KNOWN FOR MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING.
CITIES COULD DECIDE TO USE THIS
PROGRAM SO THIS IS AN OPT IN
PROGRAM IT'S NOT FORCING
LOCALITIES.
TO BE INVOLVED IT WOULD ALL AND
IT WOULD DESIGNATE AREAS TO BE
ELIGIBLE FOR THIS FINANCIAL
SUPPORT. TO DETERMINE IF A
PROJECT IS ELIGIBLE THE PROPOSED
DEVELOPMENT MUST BE INSIDE THE
CITY CITY DESIGNATED PROGRAM
AREA.
AND AT LEAST TWO THIRDS OF THE
LOCAL OF THE TOTAL SQUARE
FOOTAGE MUST BE MULTI FAMILY.
THESE DEVELOPMENTS MUST ALSO
PROVIDE AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS
BASED ON THE SET ASIDE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE PROGRAM.
INDIVIDUAL DEVELOPMENTS WOULD
RECEIVE FINANCIAL SUPPORT IN THE
FORM OF A BOND FROM CALIFORNIA
HOUSING FINANCE AUTHORITY IN
EXCHANGE FOR PROVIDING HIGH
DENSITY DEVELOPMENT WITH INCOME
RESTRICTIVE UNITS FOR FIFTY FIVE
YEARS.
THE AMOUNT OF THE BOND IS
DETERMINED BY THE DURATION OF
THE TAX ABATEMENT.
WE'RE WORKING WITH CAL HFA AND
COMBINED CONSULTING WITH THE
BOARD COM -- CONSOLE ON THE
ISSUE RAISED IN THE ANALYSIS
REGARDING HOW TO ENFORCE
COMPLIANCE WITH THE BOND
CONFIDENCE AND OTHER ISSUES WITH
BONDING AGAINST TAX INCREMENT.
THIS BILL WAS SUPPORTED BY STATE
TREASURER FIONA MOCK WHO SITS ON
CAL AT HFA CALIFORNIA U. M. B.
THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS.
WITH ME TODAY IS MIKE KINSELLA
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF UP FOR
GROWTH NATIONAL COALITION TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTEEN WITH THAT I
REQUEST FULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE [inaudible]
YOUR WITNESS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS MAKING CELL EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF UP FOR GROWTH ACTION --
IN A BROAD AND DIVERSE NATIONAL
COALITION OF STAKEHOLDERS WHO
BELIEVE THE COMMUNITY SHOULD
GROW FOR THE BENEFIT OF EVERY
PERSON.
IN OUR MISSION IS TO CREATE
AFFORDABLE AND ACCESSIBLE
COMMUNITIES BY PROVIDING MORE
HOUSING NEAR JOBS.
EFFICIENT TRANSPORTATION AND
HIGH OPPORTUNITY NEIGHBORHOODS
GUARDING OUR RESEARCH THE
REFERENCE NATIONAL COALITION WE
FOUND THE CALIFORNIA IS THREE
POINT FOUR MILLION HOME SHORT OF
MEETING HOUSING NEEDS AS
MEASURED FROM.
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY FIFTEEN FROM
TWENTY TEN TO TWENTY SIXTEEN
CALIFORNIA ONLY PRODUCED SEVEN
HOUSING UNITS FOR EVERY TEN NEW
HOUSEHOLDS FORMED IN THE STATE.
CREATING A SEVERE IMBALANCE OF
SUPPLY AND DEMAND AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTEEN CREATES A PROGRAM THAT
INCENTIVIZE IS DENSITY IN
CREATES AFFORDABLE HOMES IN HIGH
OPPORTUNITY TRANSIT SURF
NEIGHBORHOODS.
CITIES WOULD HAVE THE OPTION TO
USE THIS TAX INCREMENT TOOL TO
PROVIDE THE GAP FINANCING
NECESSARY TO MAKE THE
CONSTRUCTION OF AFFORDABLE HOMES
POSSIBLE.
THIS TOOLS DESIGNED IS GIVE
CITIES TREMENDOUS FLEXIBILITY TO
PROVIDE A MORE OR LESS
ASSISTANCE BASED ON A PROJECT
DEPENDING UPON THE LEVEL OF
AFFORDABILITY SUITED FOR A
PARTICULAR NEIGHBORHOOD.
LARGE CITIES SUCH AS LOS ANGELES
OR SAN FRANCISCO COULD
UNDERWRITE THE PROJECTS ON THEIR
OWN OR SIT SMALLER CITIES COULD
PARTNER WITH CAL HFA WHO COULD
ACT AS A CONDUIT LENDER.
AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTEEN OFFERS
TREMENDOUS PUBLIC BENEFITS IT
EXPANDS THE SUPPLY OF LOWER COST
HOMES IN AREAS WHERE ONLY MARKET
RATE UNITS ARE TRADITIONALLY
BUILT SECOND IT REDUCES THE NEED
FOR MORE BUILDABLE LAND BY
PROMOTING DENSITY.
THEY CAN LEVERAGE EXISTING
INVESTMENTS IN INFRASTRUCTURE
THIRD YOU WILL CREATE
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS REDUCING
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED BY AS
MUCH AS 35%.
BY BUILDING MORE HOUSING NEAR
TRANSIT IN FINALLY AS CITIES
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE PROGRAM
ANNUAL PROPERTY TAX REVENUE IN
THE AREA WILL INCREASE BY
APPROXIMATELY TWO POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS. FOR EVERY ONE
THOUSAND HOMES BUILT.
THANK YOU AND WE STRONG ONLY
ENCOURAGE AN AYE VOTE.
OTHER WITNESSES.
BUT LUIS MANTE FROM CALIFORNIA
BE -- I THINK THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKER IN THE AUTHOR DID A
GREAT JOB COVERING THE BILL I
WOULD JUST NOTE THAT CREATIVE --
HOUSING -- LEGISLATION LIKE IT'S
SUCH AS THIS ARE ESSENTIAL FOR
MEETING THE STATE'S --
CHRONICLES AND HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY GOALS AND URGENT
ABOUT.
LET ME ASK IF THERE ARE OTHER
SUPPORTERS OF THIS BILL.
JENNIFER SPEC ABOUT CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS AND
SUPPORT.
ALORS TALK ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
ALEX STORES ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
VETERANS SERVICE AGENCIES IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
TODD DAVID ON BEHALF OF THE BAY
AREA HOUSING ADVOCACY COALITION
SUPPORT.
MATT REAGAN FROM THE BAY AREA
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
LET ME ASK IF THERE IS ANY
OPPOSITION.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS COME MORNING
DAVID WILL FOR THE HOWARD JARVIS
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION WE ARE
OPPOSED TO MISTER CHAIRMAN I DO
APOLOGIZE FOR THE WEIGHT WATER
ON THE SPELL BUT THE LETTERS NOT
WITHOUT PRECEDENT.
WE DID OPPOSE THE AUTHORS AB
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY THREE LAST
YEAR WHICH IS SOMEWHAT SIMILAR
TO THE BILL THAT'S BEFORE US
TODAY SO.
AGAIN MY APOLOGIES -- LISTEN
MEMBERS WE DO HAVE AN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROBLEM THERE'S ONE
THIRD OF CALIFORNIA RUNNERS THAT
SPEND AT LEAST HALF THEIR TAKE
HOME PAY ON RENT.
WE NEED TO BUILD A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY THOUSAND UNITS OF NEW
HOUSING A YEAR JUST TO KEEP PACE
WITH DEMAND BUT INSTEAD WE DON'T
ABOUT HALF THAT OVER THE LAST
TWENTY YEARS THERE'S ONLY THEN
FOUR YEARS AGO WE BUILT A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY THOUSAND
UNITS OF NEW HOUSING.
SO IT IS ABUNDANTLY CLEAR THAT
WE DO NEED MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING BUT UNFORTUNATELY AND
THIS IS A LONG STANDING
PRECEDENT FOR THE HOWARD JARVIS
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION ANYTIME
YOU'RE DEALING WITH LONG TERM.
DEBT INCLUDING -- LONG TERM
DEVELOPMENT ENTITIES WHICH IS
WHAT THIS BILL WOULD ESTABLISH
WE DO BELIEVE YOU SHOULD HAVE A
TWO THIRDS VOTE BEFORE I DEBT IS
APPROVED TO ESTABLISH A
REDEVELOPMENT ENTITY AND BUILD
NEW AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE'VE
ALWAYS BELIEVE THAT AND CONTINUE
TO THINK THAT'S TRUE HERE I MEAN
THIS IS.
THAT IT'S GOING TO BE ON THE
BOOKS LONG AFTER THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS THAT
APPROVED BETTER OUT OF OFFICE --
AND IS NOT GEO DEBT YOU KNOW SO
IT'S NOT NECESSARILY BACKED BY
THE FULL FAITH AND CREDIT OF A
LOCAL MUNICIPALITY SO FOR THOSE
REASONS WE DO THINK THERE NEEDS
TO BE THE SAFEGUARD OF OUR
APPROVAL SO IT ASK FOR NOVA.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THE WISH
TO OPPOSE THIS BILL.
LET'S BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY DISCUSSION.
WHAT SAY THE AUTHOR I KNOW
YOU'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS
CONCEPT FOR A COUPLE OF YEARS
AND VERY MUCH APPRECIATE?
YOUR WORK IN THE WORK OF YOUR
SPONSORS WITH OUR COMMITTEE -- I
DO THINK THAT THIS IS VERY MUCH
WITH YOUR AUTHOR AMENDMENTS A
CREATIVE WAY AND HOW WE CAN HELP
FUNDS MULTI FAMILY HOUSING --
AND WITH THE AMENDMENTS TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE TIGHTENING UP
AFFORDABLE HOUSING COMPONENT SO
WITH THAT HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT
TODAY.
AND UNLESS THERE'S ANY.
ADDITIONAL COMMENT.
DO YOU WANT.
TO CLOSE I WOULD JUST RESPOND TO
THE GENTLEMAN FROM HER JERVIS --
BRIEFLY -- TOTALLY UNDERSTAND
THE CONCERN I WILL SAY THAT WHEN
YOU'RE DEALING WITH PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS SUCH AS
THIS YOU'RE TAKING LAND THAT.
IS UNDER DEVELOPED AND WHEN YOU
DO THESE PROJECTS YOU RAISE THE
AMOUNT OF TAXABLE REVENUE SO
EVEN THOUGH THAT REVENUE IS USED
FOR A WHILE TO PAY BACK THAT
BOND EVENTUALLY YOU HAVE AN
ASSET THAT GENERATES MUCH MORE
REVENUE. FOR THE FOR THE
MUNICIPALITY AND THAT'S
CERTAINLY BEEN MY EXPERIENCE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT SO THAT MONEY
YOU KNOW YOU'RE NOT INVESTING IT
IN SOME STOCK SOMEWHERE YOU'RE
ACTUALLY BUILDING SOMETHING THAT
YOU KNOW YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE A
GOOD RETURN ON THAT MONEY SO --
I UNDERSTAND THE CONCERN BUT I
THINK IT'S A VERY PRUDENT USE OF
PUBLIC MONEY BECAUSE AND YOU
ALSO HAVE THE BENEFIT ON LIKE
WITH A INVESTMENT A SHOPPING
MALL YOU HAVE THE BENEFIT OF OF
HOUSING YOUR COMMUNITY.
SO I THINK IT'S A VERY SMART USE
FOR COMMUNITIES WHO WANT TO USE
THIS TOOL.
AND WITH THAT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CLOTHES IS OUR MOTION ABOUT THE
SPORT [inaudible]
THEIR SECOND.
I WILL SECOND IT OF MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASTOR OF THE
COMEDIAN LOCAL GOVERNMENT CHIU
HI CHIU I GAVE.
AT FORTY GABRIELLE GABRIEL I
GLORIA [inaudible]
KILEY.
KILEY NO.
LEE MON REMOTE I MAIENSCHEIN.
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE.
I JUST WANT TO JUST CLARIFY THAT
THE AMENDMENTS THAT -- WERE
DISCUSSED WILL BE TAKEN IN THE
NEXT COMMITTEE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE -- THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION WE WAIT FOR OTHER
MEMBERS TO AT ALL.
AND WITH THAT WE HAVE TO MORE
AUTHORS MYSELF MR GABRIEL I WILL
ASK MR GABRIEL IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO PRESENT YOUR ITEM.
FILE ITEM FIFTEEN AB
.
FIFTEEN SEVENTY NINE PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TODAY 2%
EIGHTY FIFTEEN SEVENTY NINE A
BILL TO ADDRESS OUR STATE'S
CRIPPLING SHORTAGE OF STUDENT
HOUSING.
AS THIS COMMITTEE IS WELL AWARE
COLLEGE STUDENTS ARE AT THE
FOREFRONT OF OUR STATE'S HOUSING
CRISIS ACCORDING TO RECENT DATA.
19% OF COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS HAVE ENTERED
HOMELESSNESS IN THE LAST YEAR
AND ALMOST 60% HAVE FACED
HOUSING IN SECURITY.
CSU AND YOU SEE STUDENTS ALSO
REPORT ALARMINGLY HIGH RATES OF
HOMELESSNESS AND HOUSING AND
SECURITY.
AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY NINE SIX TO
ADDRESS THIS CHALLENGE BY
ELIMINATING IMPACT FEES WITH
KNOWN ACCESS THAT CAN SLOW DOWN
DEVELOPMENT AND DRIVE UP THE
COST OF NEW STUDENT HOUSING.
AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY NINE SEEKS TO
ENSURE THAT KATE TO THROUGH
TWELVE STUDENTS SCHOOL IMPACT
MITIGATION FEES CANNOT BE USED
TO DELAY THE CONSTRUCTION OF
COLLEGE HOUSING OR INCREASED
COSTS SINCE ABSENT RARE
EXCEPTIONS.
DORM LIKE APARTMENTS DO NOT
HOUSE K. THROUGH TWELVE STUDENTS.
IN SO DOING THIS MEASURE WOULD
ENSURE THAT STUDENT HOUSING IS
TREATED SIMILAR TO SENIOR
HOUSING WHERE DEVELOPERS ARE
EXEMPTED FROM PAYING IMPACT
MITIGATION FEES.
THAT HAVING BEEN SAID THIS BILL
RECOGNIZES THAT THERE MIGHT BE A
RARE EXCEPTION TO THE RULE SUCH
AS A YOUNG STUDENT COUPLE WITH A
CHILD.
IN THIS REQUIRES OWNERS TO PAY
THE APPROPRIATE FEE FOR EACH K.
TO TWELVE STUDENT THAT ACTUALLY
RESIDES IN THEIR DEVELOPMENT.
WITH ME TODAY TO TO TESTIFY ARE
TWO EXPERTS ON THE ISSUE --
SYLVIA FERRARI WITH AM CAL A
STUDENT AND AFFORDING HOUSING
AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPER
AND ALICIA HACKER A YOU SEE
DAVID STUDENT A UC DAVIS STUDENT
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
FORTY FIVE THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
YOUR WITNESSES.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
TODAY MY NAME'S LISA HOCKER AND
I'M A SECOND YEAR POLITICAL
SCIENCE PUBLIC SERVICE MAJOR
FROM UC DAVIS AND I'M HERE TODAY
TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF AB.
FIFTEEN SEVENTY NINE AND PROVIDE
A STUDENT PERSPECTIVE ON THE
GROWING HOUSING CRISIS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
JUST A TWENTY MINUTE DRIVE FROM
HERE IS THE CITY OF DAVIS A
SMALL COLLEGE TOWN THAT'S HOME
TO THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS JUST
LIKE ME. FOR PASSION ABOUT
STUDIES AND WORKING TOWARDS
MAKING THE WORLD A BETTER PLACE
ONE RELATIVELY HAD IN FACT ABOUT
THIS COLLEGE TOWN IS THE HIGH
AMOUNT OF HOUSING AND SECURITY
THAT TOUCHES NEARLY EVERY
STUDENT'S LIFE.
ACCORDING TO THE UC DAVIS
HOUSING STUDY ABOUT 7% OR CLOSE
TO IT TWO THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
STUDENTS HAVE REPORTED
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS FOR
SOME PERIOD ABOUT UC DAVIS.
A FURTHER 18% OR ABOUT SIX
THOUSAND STUDENTS HAVE REPORTED
BEING HOUSING AND SECURE FOR
SOME PERIOD.
NOT KNOWING WHERE YOU GONNA BE
ABLE TO SLEEP AT NIGHT OR FEEL
HAVE A REPORT OVER YOUR HEAD OR
HAVE TO CHOOSE BETWEEN PAYING
RENT OR HAVING A GOOD MEAL OR
BUYING YOUR BOOKS. FOR YOUR
CLASS IMPAIRS A STUDENT'S
ABILITY TO SUCCEED IN COLLEGE AB
FIFTEEN SEVENTY NINE ENCOURAGES
THE DEVELOPMENT OF MORE STUDENT
HOUSING AND WILL SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPROVE THE DAILY LIVES OF
STUDENTS.
AND ALLOW STUDENTS THE FREEDOM
TO STUDY COMPLETE THEIR DEGREE
WITHOUT THE FEAR OF NOT HAVING A
PLACE TO SLEEP AT NIGHT BUT THAT
I WANT TO THANK YOU AND ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT.
FOR EIGHTY FIFTEEN SEVENTY NINE
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBER SILVIO FERRARI
HERE ON BEHALF OF AN CAL SO AM
CAL HAS BEEN AFFORDABLE HOUSING
BUILDER FOR ABOUT THE LAST FORTY
YEARS.
ABOUT FIVE YEARS AGO AND CAL
KIND OF TOOK A STEP BACK FOR A
MINUTE AND SAID LISTEN WE'VE GOT
A GREAT DEAL OF EXPERTISE IN THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WORLD HOW CAN
WE TAKE THIS EXPERTISE.
AND APPLY IT TO OTHER AREAS
WHERE THERE'S A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF NEED.
AND OUT OF THAT STUDY OUT OF
THAT REFLECTION WHAT THEY REALLY
DISCOVERED IS THAT AS YOU JUST
HEARD THERE ARE FAR TOO MANY
COLLEGE KIDS THAT ARE PURSUING.
COLLEGE EDUCATION AT TRINA THE
DREAM OF RECEIVING THAT DIPLOMA
AND THEY ARE FACING HOMELESSNESS
THEY'RE FACING HOUSING AND
SECURITY.
SO WHAT WAS BORN OUT OF THAT WAS
A PRODUCT THAT I AM CAL HAS BEEN
REFERRING TO IS PURPOSE BUILT
STUDENT HOUSING.
IN FORM AND FUNCTION IN EVERY
WAY IT LOOKS JUST LIKE ON CAMPUS
DORMS.
IT IS A SINGLE KITCHEN SINGLE
COMMUNAL -- COMMUNAL LIVING ROOM
AND IS SURROUNDED BY INDIVIDUAL
ROOMS THAT ARE EACH INDIVIDUALLY
RENTED EACH INDIVIDUALLY LOCKED.
THEY THEN PARTNER UP WITH THE
COLLEGE OR THE UNIVERSITY AND
THE ADVERTISED THE PRODUCT
ADVERTISE IT TO THE STUDENTS --
AND THEY TRY TO WORK WITH THE
COLLEGE TO GET IT LISTED AS
OVERFLOW FOR THOSE WHO CANNOT
SECURE ON CAMPUS HOUSING.
UP PURPOSE BUILT HOUSING IS NOT
DESIGNED FOR FAMILIES IT'S NOT
CONDUCIVE FOR FAMILIES THAT'S
THAT'S WHY IN THE FIVE TO SIX
PROJECTS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
BUILT.
NO FAMILY HAS REQUESTED TO LIVE
IN ANY OF THE SITUATIONS NOR DO
WE EXPECT THEM EVER TO IN THE
FUTURE.
SO WE BELIEVE THAT -- THIS IS A
RIGHT BALANCE TO SAY -- THERE
NEEDS TO BE AN UNDERSTANDING
THAT WE ARE NOT GENERATING
STUDENTS BUT AGAIN AS THE AUTHOR
MENTION IF THEIR CASE EVER COMES
ALONG.
THERE IS A MECHANISM IN THIS
THAT WILL MAKE SURE THAT NO
DISTRICT -- IT DOES NOT RECEIVE
WHAT THEY'RE ABSOLUTELY DO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME OR CHINA.
THANK YOU LET ME ASK IF THERE
ARE OTHER SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL.
MARINO WHITE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CONSORTIUM IN SUPPORT.
LOSE MONDAY WITH CALIFORNIA'S
SPORT.
GALLERY SPOKE ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT.
PATRICK SAY WELL AS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR FOR WILL
HOUSING IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LET ME ASK IF THERE'S ANY
OPPOSITION.
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY QUESTIONS.
THAT'S WHAT I THINK THERE'S A
MOTION WITH THE BILLS ARE SECOND
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
MOVING THIS FOR I THINK IT MAKES
SENSE TO EXEMPT.
FROM SCHOOL DISTRICT FEES
HOUSING FOR STUDENTS -- AND WITH
THE EXCEPTIONS THAT YOU'VE
CREATED HERE I KNOW THIS BILL'S
GOING TO GO ON TO THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE WHERE SCHOOLS CAN WAY
ON THE EDUCATION POLICY ANGLE
BUT I THINK FROM A HOUSING
POLICY ANGLE.
THIS MAKES SENSE WE ASK IF YOU
HAVE ANY ITEMS YOU LIKE TO SAY
IN YOUR CLOTHES THE SHADED I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
SECRETARY MOTION TO PASSED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION TWO
FIVE TWO HI DAVE.
HI I GLORIA KILEY.
KILEY I IN THE MONTH.
THE MONTH I MAIENSCHEIN.
QUIRK SILVA HI QUIRK SILVA I GET
REAL HIGH EVERY ALLY.
EVEN EFFORTS TO GET OUT OF
COMMITTEE WILL WAIT FOR OTHER
MEMBERS TO ADD ON COLLEGE WE
HAVE THREE FINAL ITEMS IN THE
ARE MY BILLS SO I'M GOING TO
TURN THE GAVEL OVER TO OUR VICE
CHAIR [inaudible]
START.
OKAY WE'LL START WITH THE FILE
ITEM ONE A. B. -- ELEVEN
CHAIRMAN FOR SERVERS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR COLLEAGUES AB
ELEVEN WOULD RECREATE
REDEVELOPMENT AS A TOOL TO FUND
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
WHILE FORMER REDEVELOPMENT
DEFINITELY HAD ITS CHALLENGES
WITH REGARDS TO TYPICALLY
BETWEEN FOUR TO FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR FOR ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT THE ELIMINATION OF
REDEVELOPMENT ALSO BECAUSE OUR
STATE TO STOP INVESTING ABOUT A
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING AS WELL AS
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE.
WITH THIS BILL WE ARE NOT
PROPOSING BRING BACK THE
ECONOMIC INVESTMENTS FROM
REDEVELOPMENT ONE POINT -- BUT
WE ARE ONLY FOCUSED ON HOUSING
AND INFRASTRUCTURE ON A SMALLER
SCALE THAN FORMER REDEVELOPMENT.
OUR BILL WOULD ALLOW CITIES AND
COUNTIES TO CREATE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND INFRASTRUCTURE
AGENCIES REQUIRING AT LEAST 30%
OF THE MONEY GENERATED IN
PROJECT AREAS TO FIND HOUSING.
TO AVOID ABUSES FROM THE PASTOR
BILL HAS MANY SAFEGUARDS
REQUIREMENTS OF DETAILED RECORDS
AN INDEPENDENT AUDITS FINES FOR
VIOLATIONS NEW GOVERNANCE
PROVISIONS AND ROBUST
REPLACEMENT AND ANTI
DISPLACEMENT POLICIES.
WHILE OUR STATE CONSTITUTION
REQUIRES ALL TAXING ENTITIES ARE
RECEIVED PROPERTY TAXES A CITY A
COUNTY OR SPECIAL DISTRICT TO
PARTICIPATE THE INTENT OF OUR
BILL HAS BEEN TO MAKE COUNTY
SPECIAL DISTRICTS AND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS HOLE.
THROUGH PASTORS I'VE ACCEPTED
AMENDMENTS SUGGESTED BY THE
COUNTY SPECIAL DISTRICTS AND
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO MAKE CLEAR
THAT THEIR PROPERTY TAX
ALLOCATION WILL NOT BE IMPACTED
BY THE CREATION.
OF AN AREA IN THIS BILL THE
TOTAL AMOUNT THE STATE WOULD
HAVE TO CONTRIBUTE TO BACK FILL
SCHOOLS WOULD ALSO BE CAPPED.
THIS BILL IS A COMMON SENSE
APPROACH TO REESTABLISH.
REDEVELOPMENT ON A LIMITED SCALE
FOCUSED ON OUR STATE CURRENT
PRIORITIES AND WITH SIGNIFICANT
STATE OVERSIGHT WANT TO THANK
ALL THE MANY JOINT AUTHORS OF
THIS BILL.
AND AT THIS POINT TURN IT OVER
TO OUR WITNESS.
GOOD MORNING REBEKAH MARKETS
REPRESENTING LEADING H.
CALIFORNIA LEADING AGE
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTS NONPROFIT
PROVIDERS OF SENIOR CARE AND
SERVICES INCLUDING AFFORDABLE
SENIOR HOUSING DEVELOPERS AND
MANAGERS.
COLLECTIVELY OUR MEMBERS SERVE
OVER ONE HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
OLDER ADULTS ACROSS THE STATE.
THE DISSOLUTION OF REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCIES IS MADE IT EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT TO FINANCE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND PARTICULARLY HOUSING
THAT IS AFFORDABLE TO THOSE WERE
EXTREMELY AND VERY LOW INCOME.
THE STATE'S LACK OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND HIGHER COST OF
LIVING IS FORCED MANY OLDER
ADULTS TO LIVE ON FIXING TOWN
INCOMES AND TO POVERTY AND
HOMELESSNESS.
AS HOUSING COSTS RISE RETIREMENT
INCOME SUCH AS SOCIAL SECURITY
AND SSI HAVE REMAINED STAGNANT
AND MANY LOW INCOME OLDER ADULTS
FIND IMPOSSIBLE PAY THEIR RENT.
MORE THAN HALF OF THE PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS IN
CALIFORNIA OR OLDER ADULTS LOS
ANGELES COUNTY RECENTLY
DISCOVERED THAT WHILE THEIR
OVERALL HOMELESS POPULATION WENT
DOWN 4% AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE
NUMBER OF HOMELESS PERSONS AGE
SIXTY TWO AND OVER INCREASED 22%
IN THE SAME PERIOD.
THE AVERAGE HOUSEHOLD INCOME OF
RESIDENTS LIVING IN LEADING H.
CALIFORNIA MEMBER AFFORDABLE
SENIOR HOUSING COMMUNITY
STATEWIDE.
IS UNDER FIFTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS
PER MONTH MOST OF THE BUILDINGS
THAT SERVER THEY USE EXTREMELY
AND VERY LOW INCOME OLDER ADULTS%
WERE BUILT USING REDEVELOPMENT
FUNDING.
DESPITE NOBLE EFFORTS BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND HOUSING
ADVOCATES TO CREATE NEW SOURCES
OF FUNDING FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WE HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO
FILL THE ONE BILLION DOLLAR A
YEAR HOLE LEFT IN THE ABSENCE OF
REDEVELOPMENT.
THE OLD REDEVELOPMENT PROGRAM
HAD ITS FLAWS BUT IT'S
UNDENIABLE THAT THE PROGRAM WAS
VERY SUCCESSFUL AT PRODUCING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AB ELEVEN SIX TO REIMAGINE WHAT
WORKED FROM THE PRIOR
REDEVELOPMENT PROGRAM ALL AIMING
TO FIX WHAT DIDN'T WE APPLAUD
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU AND IS CO
AUTHORS FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP.
ON THIS ISSUE AND WE URGE LIVE
OUT.
DO WE HAVE ANY -- SUPPORTER. FOR
THIS BILL.
JENNIFER SPOKE ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS IN
SUPPORT.
AT A REGULAR IN BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WE HAVE A SUPPORT IF AMENDED.
SORRY WE'RE LATE TO ENGAGING.
THAT 30% SET ASIDE TAX RATES 10%
HIGHER THAN THE FORMER RATE
UNDER THE THE DISSOLVED RT A AND
WE PREFER TO BE AT THE 20% LEVEL.
THE OTHER ISSUES THERE'S CLEAR
IT THERE NEEDS TO BE CLARITY
AROUND THE PROVISION ABOUT --
AGENCIES PROMOTING GHG CLIMATE
POLICIES I THINK THERE NEEDS TO
BE SOME CLARIFICATION ON THAT
AND THEN WE BELIEVE THERE SHOULD
BE A PROPORTIONAL REPRESENTATION
BASED ON CONTRIBUTIONS FOR THE
GOVERNING BOARD THANKS.
HIS NAME AN ORGANIZATION PLEASE.
CAPTION RACY TECH EQUITY
COLLABORATIVE IN SUPPORT.
BRING A WHITE WITH A CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CONSORTIUM SUPPORTIVE OF
THE CONCEPT OF BRINGING BACK A
MORE ROBUST TAX INCREMENT
FINANCING TOOL.
DIFFICULT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
HI DAVID BAY AREA HOUSING
ADVOCACY COALITION IN SUPPORT.
I FORGOT ABOUT WHAT THE
NONPROFIT HOUSING ASSOCIATION OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA LIKE CGC WE
HAVE A SUPPORTING CONCERT
POSITION -- MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MICHAEL RIGHT AGAIN -- I'M HERE --
I BELIEVE I'M SORRY MISS A
PRESENTATION BUT THE AMENDMENTS
ARE GOING TO BE.
ACCEPTED -- I PUT WE'RE PART OF
A COALITION THE COUNTY SANTA
CLARA SPECIAL DISTRICTS SEE SACK --
FIRE OUT WELL -- WHO EXPRESSED A
NUMBER OF CONCERNS WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS OF THE
AUTHOR AND THE STAFF -- TO
ACCOMMODATE THOSE CONCERNS IN
THE AMENDMENTS WILL ALLOW US TO
REMOVE ANY OPPOSITION WE MAY
HAVE HAD.
THANK YOU.
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE -- IS THEIR
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL -- NONE
OPPOSITION SORRY HERE LATE FOR
US SUPPORT CONCEPT HOUSING
CALIFORNIA TYRONE BUCKLEY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
SEEING NONE OF THOSE IN
OPPOSITION.
PLEASE TAKE A SEAT.
GOOD MORNING A MISTER SHERMAN
MEMBERS -- I'M BOB NAYLOR I
REPRESENT FEELS STEAD AND
COMPANY.
WHO SUPPORTED THE GOVERNOR BROWN --
BROWN AND THE TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN EVER TO DISSOLVE
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES FIRST
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR HIS --
STEADFAST EFFORTS TO ADDRESS THE
HOUSING CRISIS.
BUT WITH ALL RESPECT --
RETURNING TO THE REDEVELOPMENT
MODEL HAS IS VERY PROBLEMATIC
FIRST REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES
WERE NOT VERY EFFICIENT AT
SPENDING THEIR HOUSING MONEY.
OF THE CALIFORNIA BUDGET PROJECT
IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN FOUND
THAT ONLY 11% OF THE MONEY WAS
SPENT ON ACTUAL HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION 31% ON DEBT SERVICE
AND SO ON THE LA -- FOUND THAT
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES HAD TWO
AND A HALF BILLION DOLLARS OF
UNSPENT HOUSING MONEY -- ON HAND
AT THE TIME OF THEIR DISSOLUTION --
THEY ALSO TENDED TO USE EMINENT
DOMAIN -- TO TAKE PROPERTIES AND
THEN LEAVE THOSE PROPERTIES --
AN USED FOR YEARS AND YEARS ALL
YOU HAVE TO DO IS LOOK AT
DOWNTOWN SACRAMENTO ON CASE
STREET TO SEE.
THE RESULTS OF FORTY YEARS OF
VACANT PROPERTY -- THE
REDEVELOPMENT MODEL IS REQUIRES
BONDING AGAINST FUTURE PROPERTY
TAX INCREMENT.
WITH THAT THAT IS A HIGH RISK
BUDGET STRATEGY BECAUSE IT
DEDICATES IT REQUIRES THE STATE
ESSENTIALLY TO BACK FILL THE
SCHOOL REVENUES FOR THIRTY OR
FORTY YEARS.
AND THIS IS BY THE WAY AND ONLY
30% OF THAT BACK FILL GETS SPENT
ON HOUSING.
FROM A CITY STANDPOINT WALLING
OFF THAT REVENUE TO PAY FOR THE
BOND DOES SERVICE MEANS.
THEY ARE RESTRICTED AND
ADDRESSING THE INCREASING
PENSION COSTS AND NEED FOR FOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND ADDRESSING
THE HOMELESS PROBLEM.
OF THE GOVERNOR IN HIS BUDGET
CHOSE A DIFFERENT WAY THAN THE
REDEVELOPMNT MODEL AND WE THINK
THE GOVERNOR HAS A BETTER WAY
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NOVA.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS COME MORNING
DAVID WOLF THE HOWARD JARVIS
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL AND FRANKLY --
MISTER CHAIR I JUST CONCUR WITH
THE ARGUMENTS OF MR NAY ARE --
LONG TERM DEBT DOES NEED VOTER
APPROVAL -- AS I TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER THIS MORNING AND ALSO
OTHER SHOULD BE EMINENT DOMAIN
PROTECTIONS -- TO ENSURE THAT
PRIVATE PROPERTY ISN'T TAKEN FOR
PRIVATE USE THEM BECAUSE THOSE
THINGS ARE NOT IN THIS BILL
WOULD ASK FOR AN OF ART ALSO.
DO WE HAVE ANYONE IN THE
AUDIENCE -- THAT'S ALSO.
IN OPPOSITION THIS BILL
SCHNEEMANN ORGANIZATION.
FOR MR MY APOLOGIES I MISS THE
SUPPORT SEGMENT NANCY TRIED AS A
SPIN OFF SITE ON BEHALF OF THE
COALITION FOR ADEQUATE SCHOOL
HOUSING WE HAD RAISING CONCERNS
EARLIER ABOUT THE IMPACT OF THIS
BILL COULD HAVE ON EDUCATION
FUNDING AND WE JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT THOSE.
CONCERNS ARE REMOVED WITH THE
AMENDMENTS OF THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN DAN CARRIED AWAY.
FROM WILL BE THE CALIFORNIA CITY
SORT OF IN THE SAME CATEGORY Là
OF LATE LATE TO THE TO THE
SUPPORT -- COLUMN.
WE ARE BOTH THINK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING FOR THIS BILL IT'S A
RECOGNITION THAT IN ORDER TO GET
BACK TO SOME OF THE TYPES OF
PROJECTS THAT.
MEMBERS IN THIS BUILDING WANT TO
SEE MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING WERE
TRANSFERRING DEVELOPMENT.
YOU'RE GONNA NEED A MORE
POWERFUL TOOL THAT THEN THE ONES
THAT ARE THERE TODAY -- WE DO
HAVE SOME SOME TECHNICAL ISSUES
WITH THE BILL AND CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR ON THOSE
BUT WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR FOR
FOR BRINGING THE IDEA FORWARD
BECAUSE IT'S PART OF THE REALITY
OF OF ACTUALLY GETTING GETTING
US BACK TO A MORE WORKABLE TOOL.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
HEARING NONE ANY -- DO YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
IT'S A KILEY.
GOOD MORNING SIR TO AYE YOU
MENTIONED SOMETHING IN YOUR
REMARKS ABOUT HOW THIS -- BILL --
WILL NOT PROVIDE IS BROUGHT TO
MANDATE -- FOR ECONOMIC
REDEVELOPMENT IS THE PRIOR -- WE
DON'T WE JUST COULD YOU EXPLAIN
THAT LITTLE MORE WHAT THAT
DISTINCTION IS ABSOLUTELY AND
THAT IS ENTIRELY TRUE SO LET'S
JUST GO BACK TO WHAT
REDEVELOPMENT USED TO BE.
OUR STATE SPENT FIVE TO SIX
BILLION DOLLARS ABOUT 80% OF
THAT MONEY WENT TO ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND 20% THAT MONEY
WAS SET ASIDE.
FOR HOUSING AND INFRASTRUCTURE --
IT WAS THE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
PARTS OF IT THAT WERE REALLY --
WHAT WERE THE CRITICISMS AROUND
ABUSE -- MONIES WERE SPENT TO
BUILD STRIP MALLS TO BUILD
MERMAID BARS IN SACRAMENTO
EXCEPT TRUCK.
AND I AM NOT PROPOSING THAT WE
ARE BRINGING BACK TAX INCREMENT
FINANCING TOOL TO DO ANY OF THAT
WHAT I AM PROPOSING IS THE
PORTION WITH REGARDS TO HOUSING
AND INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WEEK
GIVEN THIS CRISIS WE HAVE RIGHT
NOW BOTH OF THOSE FRONTS.
THAT'S WHAT TAX INCREMENT
FINANCING SHOULD BE USED SO
WE'RE ONLY TALKING ABOUT SAY THE
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR THAT WE
HAVE LOST.
AND GIVEN THE HOUSING CRISIS
THAT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW -- I
THINK ALL CITIES AND COUNTIES
WOULD LOVE TO SEE THAT MONEY
COME BACK SO I IT AND THE OTHER
THING THAT I KNOW YOU UNDERSTAND
ABOUT TAX INCREMENT FINANCING --
YOU KNOW THE HOPE IS THAT WE'RE
GOING TO WE'RE GONNA USE THESE
FUNDS AND PROPERTY TAX VALUES
WILL GO UP SO IF WE DON'T MAKE
AN INVESTMENT -- ZERO TIMES ZERO
IS NOT GONNA LEAD TO ANY GROWTH --
ONE THING THAT'S IMPORTANT ABOUT
THIS BILL IS WE PUT IN MANY.
SAFEGUARDS TO AVOID THE ABUSES
OF THE PAST AND I DO UNDERSTAND
GIVEN WHAT HAPPENED IN THE PAST
THERE JUST A LOT OF CONCERNS
THAT PEOPLE HAVE ABOUT WHAT WE
DO IN THE FUTURE.
WE DELIBERATELY PUT AND DETAILED
RECORD RICKY RECORD KEEPING AN
INDEPENDENT AUDIT REQUIREMENTS
FINES FOR VIOLATIONS SIGNIFICANT
GOVERNANCE PROVISIONS -- ROBUST
PROVISIONS AROUND REPLACEMENT
ANTI DISPLACEMENT TO REALLY
ADDRESS WHAT HAPPENED IN THE
PAST BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT TO
OBVIOUSLY GO BACK.
BUT MY PERSPECTIVE THE BABY DID
GET THROWN OUT WITH THE BATH
WATER AS I THINK YOU MAY KNOW
FROM REDEVELOPMENT HISTORY --
THE INTENT TO WIN THE
LEGISLATURE VOTED TO END ASPECTS
OF REDEVELOPMENT WERE NOT ENDED
THERE WAS ESSENTIALLY A STRIPPED
DOWN VERSION REPLACEMENT BUT
BECAUSE OF A LAWSUIT.
EVERYTHING ENDED UP GETTING
THROWN OUT AND WE ARE NOW IN THE
PLACE THAT WE ARE AND SO OUR
GOAL IS TO KEEP WHAT.
WE NEED FROM SO CALLED
REDEVELOPMENT ATTACKS AND COMMIT
FINANCING BUT TO ENSURE THAT --
THAT THE EXCESSES OF THE PAST
ARE NOT BROUGHT BACK.
GOT AND I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
EFFORT TO TO TRY TO REIN IN SOME
OF THE THE ABUSES THAT WE SAW.
THAT YOU KNOW IT SAYS THAT 30%
OF THE MONEY HERE'S TO BE SET
ASIDE FOR LOW INCOME HOUSING SO
WHERE WERE MY THE OTHER 70% WIND
UP CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE WE TO
FIND THAT VERY CAREFULLY
WHATEVER YOU WOULD UNDERSTAND TO
BE SORT OF INFRASTRUCTURE YOU
NEED TO BUILD.
AROUND HOUSING TO MAKE CHASE A
COMMUNITY WORK THAT'S WHAT WE
WOULD SET IT ASIDE FOR ONE THING
I'LL JUST SAY ABOUT THAT NUMBER
IT IS CERTAINLY TRUE THAT IN
REDEVELOPMENT ONE POINT NO.
THE NUMBER WAS 20% -- THERE'S
ANOTHER BILL MOVING IN THE
SENATE THAT SUGGESTING THAT
NUMBER OUGHT TO BE 50% WE
THOUGHT TO SORT OF STRIKE IT
DOWN THE MIDDLE 30% 70%.
I AM OPEN TO WHAT THAT NUMBER
SHOULD BE BASED ON WHAT THE
CONSENSUS OF THE BODY IS BUT WE
CERTAINLY THINK GIVEN THE
HOUSING CRISIS AND THE
INFRASTRUCTURE CRISES THAT WE'RE
IN RIGHT NOW.
WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING MORE
THAN WHAT WE ARE DOING.
IT DOES THE BILL -- CONTAIN ANY
OTHER CONSTRAINTS ON THE USE OF
EMINENT DOMAIN I SUPPOSE WHAT
YOU JUST SAID COULD BE
CONSIDERED ONE CONSTRAINT IN
TERMS OF THE TYPE OF PROJECTS
WHERE THERE'S A THEIR SUBJECTS
THAT WERE CONDEMNATION CAN BE.
USED AS A TOOL BUT OTHER OTHER --
LIMITS -- IN THIS BILL THAT
DIDN'T EXIST IN THE PREVIOUS
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES WE DON'T
ADDRESS THAT IN OUR BILL -- WE'D
BE IT JUST WASN'T A TOPIC WE
THOUGHT WE NEEDED WHAT WE WE
OUGHT TO ADDRESS IN THIS BILL
WHAT I WILL SAY IS THERE ARE --
MANY CHALLENGES TO MOVING
FORWARD WITH EMINENT DOMAIN
THERE ARE.
MANY HURDLES THAT A LOCAL
JURISDICTION IS TO GO THROUGH
BUT THAT WASN'T OR HAS NOT BEEN
A FOCUS OF THIS BILL -- YEAH I'D
ENCOURAGE THAT TO BE -- YOU KNOW
SOME OF THE WE GIVE SOME
ATTENTION TO BECAUSE I THINK
THAT THERE WAS A TRACK RECORD OF
IT BEING USED IN SOME WAYS THAT
WERE -- PRETTY -- FOR BAD FOR
PRIVATE PROPERTY RIGHTS IN THE
PAST -- IF FINAL QUESTION YOU
KNOW -- THIS IN ANOTHER WAY ON
THAT POINT WE DO HAVE PROVISIONS
THERE WERE MANY TIMES WHEN
EMINENT DOMAIN WAS USE THAT
ENDED UP DISPLACING SENSITIVE
AND VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES.
AND AND WITHOUT ANY SENSE OF
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN OF THOSE
COMMUNITIES AFTERWARDS AND WE DO
HAVE PROVISIONS IN THE BILL TO
DEAL WITH THAT.
OKAY IT'S GOOD TO HEAR -- AND
THERE'S A STATISTIC GOT MISTER
NEVER MENTIONS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA BUDGET PROJECT THAT
ONLY ABOUT 11%.
OF THE FUNDS I PREVIOUSLY WOULD
IN THE ACTUAL CONSTRUCTION YOU
HAVE ANY SENSE OF OF WHY THAT
WAS SO LOW AND HOW THAT.
IS BEING ADDRESSED HERE I THINK
YOU JUST BE THE NUMBER I I THINK
THAT'S CORRECT -- I DON'T
DISPUTE THE NUMBER I THINK THE
REALITY IS -- THE STATE AND WAS
NOT IN THE HOUSING CRISIS THAT
WE'RE IN NOW AND BOY IF WE COULD
HAVE TWO AND A HALF BILLION
DOLLARS TO SPEND ON HOUSING I
HAVE A FEELING OUR COLLEAGUES
WOULD KNOW HOW TO USE IT.
WE HAVE A OF MOTION AND ANY
SECOND ON THE FLOOR ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I GUESS JUST HAVE -- ONE GERMAN
IN IN YOUR OPENING REMARKS YOU
HAD MENTIONED THAT -- YOU TO
SOME AMENDMENTS AND THAT LISTED
OF SOME OPPOSITIONS -- I'D.
I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT A FLOOD
IF YOU DO YOU KNOW IF -- THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS IN THE THE CTA.
ARE THEY STILL NEUTRAL IN THIS
OR OR TO THE AMENDMENTS THAT YOU
ACCEPTED DID I BRING HIM TO TO
NEUTRALITY OR IT'S IT'S A GOOD
QUESTION THERE THEY'RE NOT HERE
I I DON'T KNOW. FOR SURE -- THE
ISSUE THAT THEY HAD REYES WERE
AROUND SPECIAL DISTRICTS AND
MAKING SURE THAT WE WERE KEEPING
THEM WHOLE AND THAT WAS THE
INTENT OF THE MOMENT SO WE'VE
TAKEN AT THE REQUEST OF THE
COUNTY SPECIAL DISTRICTS IN
SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
THAT THEIR PROPERTY TAX
ALLOCATION WOULD BE IMPACTED SO
WE'VE TAKEN THOSE MOMENTS I DO
HOPE IT GOES A LONG WAY TOWARD
ADDRESSING THOSE CONCERNS BUT I
JUST DON'T KNOW WHERE THEY ARE
AT THIS POINT.
THANK YOU SIR -- IN IN WITH THAT --
YOU MAY CLOSE.
UP VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THIS
CONVERSATION THIS HAS A AS AS WE
ALL KNOW IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
THIS WAS A VERY DIFFICULT
CONVERSATION I THINK THERE'S
BEEN A LOT OF BUYER'S REMORSE --
BUT WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT HOW --
TO TO USE A ROBUST TOOL TO BUILD
A HOUSING AND INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT ARE COMMUNITIES NEED I
THINK ALL OF US KNOW THAT OUR
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS -- HAVE BEEN
ASKING FOR SOMETHING IN THIS
AREA AND SORE HOPE IS THAT WE
ARE BUILDING CONSENSUS ON WHAT
THIS TAKES LOOK FOR TO FUTURE
CONVERSATIONS ON WAYS THAT WE
CAN KEEP IMPROVING THIS.
BUT AT THIS POINT I CERTAINLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT IF YOU CAN.
THANK YOU AND MOVE WITH THAT --
I I WOULD JUST SAY THE CROW.
WHERE WHERE I AM -- CAN I
SUPPORT THE BILL RIGHT NOW BUT
I'M OPEN TO SUPPORTING IT ON THE
FLOOR.
IF WE CAN GET SOME OF THE GROUP.
TO A TO BE NEUTRAL ON IT SO THE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION TO PASSED THE COMEDIAN
LOCAL GOVERNMENT [inaudible]
DAVE.
NO.
GABRIEL.
GLORIA AYE GLORIA AYE
[inaudible]
KILEY.
KILEY NO.
LEE MON THE MONTH I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN NIGHT QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE GABRIEL GABRIEL
HI [inaudible]
CHIU [inaudible]
HI.
THAT MOTION DOES PASS ON TO
COMMITTEE ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT
[inaudible]
YEAH.
THEY WERE DONE RIGHT.
WE HAVE TWO OF AYE TWO OTHER
IDEAS TO WORK AND I THINK THE
NEXT ITEM IS FILE ITEM.
TWELVE A FIVE FIVE ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE OF AB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN EIGHTY
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN COLLEAGUES
THIS IS A BILL TO ADDRESS THE
HOUSING CRISIS IN THE BAY AREA --
AS ALL OF YOU I BELIEVE KNOW OUR
REGION HAS BEEN THE EPICENTER OF
THE STATE'S HOUSING CRISIS WITH
RECORD HOME PRICES RENTS AND
HOMELESSNESS LEVELS WITH
COUNTLESS RESIDENTS TO SPEND
HOURS DRIVING EVERY DAY.
WHO ARE ONE PAYCHECK AWAY FROM
EVICTION WHO ARE CONTEMPLATING
MOVING OUT OF OUR STATE?
THE BAY AREA FACES IS CRISIS FOR
A NUMBER OF REASONS BUT ONE IN
PARTICULAR AS A REGION WE HAVE
FAILED TO PRODUCE HOUSING AT ALL
INCOME LEVELS WE FAILED TO
PRESERVE AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
WE FAIL TO PROTECT RESIDENTS
FROM DISPLACEMENT AT A TIME WHEN
JOB CREATION HAS BEEN AT A
RECORD HIGH WITH OUR REGION.
WELL HOUSING IS A REGIONAL ISSUE
THAT REQUIRES POLICY AND FUNDING
COORDINATION THERE HAS NOT BEEN
THIS REGIONAL APPROACH IN THE
BAY.
INSTEAD WE HAVE A HUNDRED AND
ONE CITIES AND NINE COUNTIES
MAKING INDIVIDUAL DECISIONS --
THAT OF UNFORTUNATELY NOT
ADDRESS THE CRISIS.
THE CONCEPT FOR THIS BILL CAME
FROM A DIVERSE COALITION F BAY
AREA HOUSING STAKEHOLDERS THAT
ARE TYPICALLY AT ODDS.
WHO CAME TOGETHER TO ASK THE
STATE TO EMPOWER OUR REGION TO
HELP OURSELVES?
BECAUSE NO PUBLIC ENTITY IN THE
BAY AREA HAS BEEN FOCUSED ON
HOUSING THIS BILL WOULD
ESTABLISH A REGIONAL HOUSING
ENTITY WHICH WE REFER TO AS THE
HOUSING ALLIANCE FOR THE BAY
AREA.
LIKE PREVIOUS STATE BILLS IT
CREATED THE BAY AREA TOLL
AUTHORITY TO FOCUS ON
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING.
AND THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
RESTORATION AUTHORITY TO FOCUS
ON THE BAY THIS BILL WOULD
ESTABLISH.
AN ENTITY FOCUSED ON A REGION'S
HOUSING NEEDS.
IT'S ESTIMATED THAT OUR REGION
ALONE NEEDS AN ADDITIONAL TWO
AND A HALF A BILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR TO ADDRESS OUR HOUSING
NEEDS ARE FOR WASHING NEEDS. TO
THIS ENTITY WOULD BE ABLE TO
PROPOSE REVENUE MEASURES ON THE
BALLOT IN THE NINE COUNTY BAY
AREA REGION.
A SELF HELP APPROACH TO ENABLE
OUR REGION TO RAISE REVENUES
WITHOUT FURTHER BURDENING THE
STATE.
THESE REVENUES WOULD BE ADDITIVE
TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING FUNDING
ALREADY AVAILABLE IN THE REGION
AND THE ENTITY WOULD NOT DIVERT
ANY EXISTING FUNDING STREAMS
FROM LOCAL JURIST TIONS.
WITH THESE FUNDS THE ENTITY
WOULD PROVIDE CRITICAL FUNDING
TO HOUSING PROJECTS AROUND THE
BAY PROVIDE STAFF SUPPORT AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
FUND TENANTS SERVICES SUCH AS
EMERGENCY RENTAL ASSISTANCE AND
ACCESS TO COUNSEL.
A SIMPLE PARCELS AND ACQUIRE
LAND TO BUILD HOUSING AND
MONITOR REPORT ON PROGRESS AT A
REGIONAL LEVEL.
I WANT TO MAKE IT VERY CLEAR
THIS BODY WOULD HAVE NO
AUTHORITY TO REGULATE WARNED
FORCED LAND USE DECISIONS OR
CHOIR PROPERTY BY EMINENT DOMAIN --
THE BODY WOULD BE GOVERNED BY
BOARD COMPOSED OF LOCAL ELECTED
OFFICIALS WITH AN ADVISORY BODY
COMPRISED OF REGIONAL HOUSING
EXPERTS.
ARE BAY AREA HOUSING CRISIS NOT
ONLY THREATENS THE BAY AREA BUT
MAJOR ECONOMIC DRIVERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THIS BILL WOULD
EMPOWER OUR REGION TO FINALLY
ADDRESS OUR REGIONAL HOUSING
CRISIS.
WITH THAT LIKE TO TURN OVER TO
ONCE IS STARTING WITH YOU TO
ROUTE FROM ENTERPRISE COMMUNITY
PARTNERS.
HI MY NAME IS KEEP THE ROW AND
I'M WITH ENTERPRISE CAN YOU
PARTNERS AND WE ARE DELIGHTED TO
BE STE CO SPONSORING AB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN XIN IS TO
CREATE OPPORTUNITY FOR LOW AND
MODERATE INCOME FAMILIES THROUGH
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AND LAST YEAR I CO AUTHORED THIS
REPORT IT'S CALLED ELEPHANT IN
THE REGION CHARTING A PATH FOR
THE BAY AREA MEASURE TO LEAD A
BOLD REGIONAL HOUSING AGENDA.
AND YES IT DOES HAVE AN ELEPHANT
ON IT.
AND WHAT THIS REPORT DID IS WE
LOOKED AT OTHER REGIONS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY TO SEE HOW THEY'RE
ADDRESSING THEIR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CRISIS.
AND FOR THOSE REGIONS THAT HAVE
THAT HAVE DONE IT WELL THERE'S A
KEY THERE'S A KEY FINDING.
AND THAT'S THAT THEY HAVE BUILT
A ROBUST HOUSING INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND THAT INFRASTRUCTURE HAS
INCLUDED THE FIRST COMPONENT IS
FUNDING AND THE SECOND COMPONENT
IS CAPACITY CAPACITY TO
ADMINISTER PROGRAMS AND POLICIES.
AND ALSO DEPLOY INNOVATIVE --
FINANCING SOLUTIONS.
SO WE ARE INVESTED IN THIS
LEGISLATION.
BECAUSE IT IS A BOLD REGIONAL
HOUSING SOLUTION AND IT BEGINS
TO SAT.
THAT ROBUST HOUSING
INFRASTRUCTURE THE BAY AREA
NEEDS.
RIGHT NOW -- WE RELY ON OUR
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO SOLVE THE
ENTIRE AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS.
IN THEIR SIMPLY THERE SIMPLY
ISN'T CAPACITY THERE AFTER
REDEVELOPMENT WHAT YOU'VE JUST
BEEN TALKING ABOUT AFTER WAS
DISSOLVED.
A LOT OF THE HOUSING DEPARTMENTS
ON THEIR STAFF IS BEING GUIDED
THEY DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES
AND THEY DON'T HAVE THE KNOW HOW.
AND SO THIS BILL IS REALLY --
IT'S TO HELP THESE JURISDICTIONS
IT'S A SET OF CARROTS IT'S
FUNDING IT'S TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AT STAFFING CAPACITY
IT HELPS WITH DATA AND
MONITORING MODERNI.
AND THERE'S NO STICKS AROUND
EMINENT DOMAIN OUR LAND USE
AUTHORITY.
SO ENTERPRISE WE'VE BEEN
ENGAGING -- HOUSING DEPARTMENTS
AND HOUSING AGENCIES TO FIND OUT
HOW COULD THE HOUSING ALLIANCE
OF THE BAY AREA HELP THEM.
AND THEY'VE GIVEN EXAMPLES AFTER --
THE WILD FIRES TO HELP HAVE HELP
ARE DEPLOYING INNOVATIVE
FINANCING RESOURCES TO REBUILD
COMMUNITIES AND HOUSING -- TO
HELP PROVIDE THE GAP FUNDING IN
ATLANTA SIMPLY NEEDED FOR TEO DE
DEVELOPMENTS.
AND ALSO FOR WITH HELP FOR
JURISDICTIONS TO ADMINISTER
TENET PROTECTIONS.
AND SO AND ALSO FOR THE PAST
YEAR AND OUR PRICES BUT WORKING
REALLY CLOSELY WITH A CORE GROUP
OF EQUITY ADVOCATES AND IN THIS
BILL -- THE PRESERVATION AND THE
PROTECTION AS IT'S JUST IS
BALANCED ALONG WITH THE
PRODUCTION.
SO -- THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY AND WE URGE YOUR A
VOTE.
UP TO CHAIR MEMBERS AT MATT
REAGAN WITH THE BAY AREA COUNCIL
AGAIN -- HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL I'M JUST FOR SOME
PERSPECTIVE -- AND WHY THIS BILL
IS NECESSARY IN OUR REGION --
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA
REGION IS THE FASTEST GROWING
DEVELOP ECONOMY IN THE WORLD
WERE GROWING AT ABOUT FOUR POINT
3% A YEAR.
WE'RE ADDING IN SOME MONTHS TEN
THOUSAND NEW JOBS A MONTH -- OUR
LITTLE NINE COUNTY AREA -- OUR
ECONOMY IS LARGER THAN FORTY
FIVE STATES -- SO IT'S A IT'S
OUR OUR JOB CREATORS ARE ARE
DOING A FANTASTIC JOB OF
CREATING JOBS BUT WE DON'T HAVE
THE TOOLS IN THE TOOLBOX -- TO
CREATE A SUFFICIENT NUMBER OF
NEW HOUSING UNITS TO ACCOMMODATE
THAT GROWTH -- WE BUY A QUIRK OF
HISTORY AS AS AS CHAIRMAN CHIU
SAD -- WE DEVELOPED A VERY
BALKANIZED WAY AS A REGION WITH
NINE KIND IS A HUNDRED AND ONE
CITIES.
PEER METROS LIKE NEW YORK OR
CHICAGO THEY THEY ANNEXED THEIR
BORROWS AND AND A HALF CREATED
REGIONAL SOLUTIONS TO THEIR
HOUSING PROBLEM WE DID THAT TO A
DEGREE WITH WITH AIR QUALITY WE
HAVE A WIN AT BAY AREA AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT LATER ADDRESS
OUR TRAFFIC ACT CONCERNS TO
ADDRESS.
SEA LEVEL RISE CONCERNS.
BUT OUR BIGGEST CONCERN IS IS
HOUSING AND WE DON'T HAVE A
REGIONAL SOLUTION TO THAT.
THIS BILL WOULD CREATE A
REGIONAL FUNDING MECHANISM TO
HELP.
THOSE ONE HUNDRED AND ONE CITIES
AND NINE COYOTES HAVE A A
REGIONAL APPROACH IN A REGIONAL
FOCUS TO SOLVING OUR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING -- CRISIS THIS DOES NOT
USURP THEIR AUTHORITY IT
AUGMENTS THEIR ABILITY -- SO WE
WOULD URGE AN AYE VOTE AND JUST
TODAY WE WE HAVE -- PUBLISHED A
REPORT ON THE REGION'S
HOMELESSNESS PROBLEM AND TO
SHARE SOME DATA FROM THAT REPORT
THREE HUNDRED AND SIX THOUSAND
HOMES IN THE BAY AREA.
OR BELOW 30% A AM I 50% OF THOSE
HOMES ARE PAYING SORRY TWO
THIRDS OF THOSE -- HOUSEHOLDS
ARE PAYING OVER 50% OF THEIR
TAKE HOME PAY ON RENT -- OUR
HOUSING CRISIS IS CREATED
GENERATIONAL POVERTY AND WE
DON'T HAVE THE TOOLS IN OUR
TOOLBOX TO GET FAMILIES OUT OF
GENERATIONAL POVERTY.
THIS WON'T SOLVE IT BY ITSELF
BUT IT IS ONE ADDITIONAL TOO
LITTLE HELP OUR RESOLVE OUR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS WE
ORIGINALLY THOUGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANY -- A
WITNESS IN SUPPORT THIS BILL IN
IN THE IN THE INTEREST OF TIME I
GUESS AS FOR NAME ORGANIZATIONS.
MICHAEL IN MISSILE CONDO AT HOME
IS STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MICHELLE PERCENT PUBLIC
ADVOCATES WE ARE SUPPORT IF
AMENDED AND LOVE THE THREE PIECE
FRAMING.
LOOK FORWARD TO BEING IS FOR
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
KEVIN RACY TECH EQUITY
COLLABORATIVE WERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
TYRONE BUCKLEY HOUSING
CALIFORNIA ALSO SPORT.
HI ELIZABETH MY EMPLOYER THE SAN
FRANCISCO FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
TODD DAVID BAY AREA HOUSING UP
TO SEE COALITION IN SUPPORT.
I FORGOT ABOUT WITH THE
NONPROFIT HOUSING ASSOCIATION IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AS A CO
SPONSOR AND SUPPORT.
KAREN CAMACHO WITH THE HOUSING
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL SAN MATTEO
COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
HOLLY FOR MANY WHITE HOUSE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF A
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY EAST BAY
SILICON VALLEY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU -- DO WE HAVE A NEED A
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL.
YEAH MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
COME MORNING AGAIN DAVID WILL
FOR THE HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION OPPOSITION TO YOU AB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN AND
MEMBERS AS IT'S BEEN SAID I'LL
SAY IT AGAIN WE HAVE AN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA LISTEN THE
ONLY 30% OF CALIFORNIANS CAN
AFFORD A MEDIAN PRICED HOME IN
THE STATE.
IT COSTS THREE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS ON
AVERAGE TO BUILD AN AFFORDABLE
UNITS OF HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA
IN THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA
IT'S OVER SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO BUILD A UNIT OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
SO IT IS VERY CLEAR THAT WE NEED
MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
MEMBERS WE DO BELIEVE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS A ROLE TO PLAY
IN PROVIDING ADDITIONAL
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
BUT WHEN ONLY 30% OF
CALIFORNIANS CAN AFFORD A MEDIAN
PRICED HOME ADVOCATING -- FOR
NEW PERSONAL TAXES WHICH ARE
VERY REGRESSIVE WHICH DIRECTLY
IMPACT PROPERTY OWNERS ARE NOT
GONNA DO ANYTHING TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AND AGAIN WE DO BELIEVE THE
LEGISLATURE HAS A ROLE TO PLAY
THEY CAN LOWER IMPACT FEES THEY
CAN REFORM INCLUSIONARY ZONING
TO ACTUALLY PROMOTE UNIT
DEVELOPMENT.
THEY CAN REMOVE COSTLY MANDATES
A NEW DEVELOPMENT INCLUDING RENT
CONTROL AND SOLAR PANELS ON NEW
HOMES -- THEY CAN REMOVE
REGULATORY BURDENS ON SEQUEL
LOST -- MAINTAINING ALL OF ITS
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTIONS WHICH
WE WOULD BE IN SUPPORT OF WE
NEED TO TAKE THE STEPS MEMBERS
AND NOT JUST LOOK AT AUTHORIZING
NEW REVENUE SOURCES TO FIX THIS
PROBLEM.
REVENUE HAS A PIECE TO THAT WE
DIDN'T TAKE A POSITION ON THE
HOUSING BOND LAST YEAR WHEN IT
WAS ON THE BALLOT.
YOU KNOW REVENUE DOES HAVE A
ROLE TO PLAY IN THIS BUT IT'S
NOT THE ONLY ROLE I THINK THIS
LEGISLATURE CAN DO MORE NEEDS TO
DO MORE BEFORE WE ADVANCEMENT
PROGRAMS SUCH AS THIS TASK FOR
AN OVER.
THANK YOU WAS THE WOLF -- ANYONE
ELSE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
SEEING HEARING NONE OF QUESTION
OR COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
WHO'S BEEN IN MOTION AND A
SECOND OF THIS GERMAN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
ME JUST CLARIFY A FEW THINGS AND
APPRECIATE THE PERSPECTIVE FROM
HOWARD JARVIS SO THIS BILL DOES
NOT.
AUTOMATICALLY AUTHORIZE REVENUES
WHAT IT DOES IS IT ESTABLISHES A
REGIONAL BODY MADE UP OF LOCAL
ELECTED OFFICIALS THAT COULD
DECIDE AMONG A VARIETY OF
POTENTIAL REVENUE OPTIONS.
WHETHER TO PROPOSE A BALLOT
MEASURE THAT GOES TO WITH THE
NINE COUNTY BAY AREA REGION.
SO THAT VOTERS COULD APPROVE
THESE REVENUES SO I WANNA MAKE
THAT VERY CLEAR -- SECONDLY --
WE HAVE A VERY WE HAVE AN
INTENSE HOUSING CRISIS AROUND
THE STATE BUT IN THE BAY AREA AS
WE ALL KNOW IT'S INCREDIBLY
ACUTE.
AS I MENTIONED BEFORE WE HAVE A
TWO AND A HALF BILLION DOLLAR
FUNDING NEED AROUND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND RATHER THAN ASKING
THE REST OF THE STATE TO PICK
THAT UP WHAT WE ARE SAYING AS A
REGION IS WE WANT HELP OURSELVES
WE KNOW THAT OUR REGION HAS BEEN.
ECONOMICALLY SUCCESSFUL AND AS
YOU'VE JUST HEARD THERE ARE MANY
STAKEHOLDERS FROM THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY -- FROM EQUITY GROUPS
AND EVERYONE IN BETWEEN WHO
BELIEVE THAT WE CAN.
HOPE OURSELVES TO ADDRESSES BUT
WE NEED TO COME TOGETHER AS A
REGION WE HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO
DO THIS AS A HUNDRED AND ONE
SEPARATE CITIES AS NINE SEPARATE
COUNTIES -- AND WITHOUT NOT ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT IN A STABLE
SHEEN A REGIONAL ENTITY SO WE
CAN START THIS CONVERSATION.
THANK YOU SIR OF THE SECRETARY
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
OUR MOTION TO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT
GAVE.
NINE FORTY AND FOURTEEN APRIL.
GABRIEL I GLORIA GLORIA I KILEY.
KILEY NO LEE MON.
THE MONEY I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN NIGHT QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA NO [inaudible]
CHIU [inaudible]
I OF THIS CHAIRMAN YOU HAVE THE
OF THE VOTE TO GET THIS OUT OF
COMMITTEE THANKS VERY MUCH AND
OF MY APOLOGIES THERE'S A
COMMITTEE THAT'S BEEN WAITING
FOR ME FOR MANY MINUTES TO
COMMON.
BUT MISTER GLORIA IS A FAR
BETTER SOFTBALL PLAYER THAN I
AND SO I'VE ASKED IN A PINCH IT.
ON THIS.
ONE BUT WE DO HAVE WE DO HAVE
TIME FOR YOU THAT WE HAVE A
LITTLE BIT.
YEAH WE WELL -- THANK RACES.
THE GERMAN WE WILL TAKE UP NOW
ITEM OF FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTEEN AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY
THREE YOU MAY OPEN SIR THANK YOU
THE SHOULD BE A SHORT ITEM AND
APPRECIATE MR GLORIA BEING
WILLING.
TO MOVING QUICKLY APPRECIATE
THAT VERY BRIEFLY -- THIS IS A
BILL THAT WOULD PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL DENSITY BONUSES FOR A
100% AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS
TO ADDRESS A NUMBER OF
CHALLENGES WE ALL KNOW THAT
ZONING IS OFTEN A BEAR TO
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT.
EXISTING ZONING DENSITY IN
HEIGHT ARE OFTEN TOO LOW FOR
THESE PROJECTS THE PENCIL OUT.
CERTAINLY UP FUNDING FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS VERY
SCARCE AND WE WANT TO STRETCH
EVERY DOLLAR WE CAN'T BRED TO
BUILD MORE UNITS PER DOLLAR.
AND THEN THIRDLY FOR FOR WHAT
HOUSING DEVELOPERS THAT ARE
COMPETING WITH MARKET RATE
DEVELOPERS FOR SITE MORE DENSITY
CAN MAKE A PROJECT FINANCIALLY
FEASIBLE TO GIVE THAT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPER THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMPETE.
UNDER THIS BILL THESE PROJECTS
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR AN 80%
DENSITY BONUS ABOVE EXISTING
ZONE DENSITY AND FOR INCENTIVES
OR CONCESSIONS.
ARE -- FOR IF THEY'RE PROJECTS
THAT ARE NEAR TRANSIT THEY WOULD
BE ELIGIBLE FOR UNLIMITED
DENSITY BONUSES PLUS AN INCREASE
IN HEIGHT OR FOR AREA RATIO UP
TO A LIMIT.
SO WITH THAT LIKE TO TURN OVER
TO MS WHITE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CONSORTIUM ARE BILL
SPONSOR.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS RAIN A
WHITE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CONSORTIUM PROUD TO BE A
SPONSORING THIS SPELL IT'S
REALLY CRITICAL FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS AND REALLY
APPRECIATE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU CARRYING
THIS BILL I AS AS YOU KNOW
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
FACE MANY CHALLENGES AND
BUILDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING --
AND ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO SORT
OF GIVE THEM THE FLEXIBILITY TO
TO MAKE A PROJECT PENCIL AS WELL
AS POSSIBLE IS VERY IMPORTANT
FOR US TO DO ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT
OF LIMITED RESOURCES -- AND WHAT
WHAT I WANT TO JUST MAKE NOTE OF
UNDER EGGS ALL OF THE FINANCING
PROGRAMS THAT A FOR A HOUSING
DEVELOPERS USE.
THEY ALREADY HAVE IT MANY
REQUIREMENTS MINIMUM UNIT SIZES --
THE DENSITY BONUS PROGRAM ALLOWS
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO IMPLEMENT
THEIR OWN PROGRAM THEY'RE STILL
LOCAL STANDARDS AND SO WE'RE NOT
TRYING TO JUST BUILD SOME
MASSIVE BOX WITH IN CRAMPED MANY
HOUSEHOLDS AS POSSIBLE AND IT
BUT TO JUST GIVE A LITTLE BIT
MORE FLEXIBILITY AND ALLOW
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS.
TO PRODUCE THE NECESSARY UNITS
THAT WE NEED TO STATEWIDE -- SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME OR DRIVE
OUT TODAY.
THANK YOU -- DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESS IN SUPPORT THIS BILL HIS
NAME AN ORGANIZATION PLEASE
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MORE TOP ON BEHALF OF SAN DIEGO
MAYOR KEVIN FAULCONER IN THE
ENTIRE CITY COUNCIL IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
BRIAN AGAINST ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
FOR MANY WITH WHITE HOUSE PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF A HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
SURE MEMBERS RAND MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION A VERY STRONG SUPPORT.
MICHAEL I WAS SO A CONDO AT HOME
IN SUPPORT.
I KNOW OUR WITH QUESTIONS FROM A
PARTY IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE ELSE -- HEARING SEEING
NONE DO WE HAVE ANY -- MEMBERS --
UP THE OPPOSITION'S THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SAY ANYTHING.
SEEING HEARING ON ANY --
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
MOVED BY A SHARON QUIRK SILVA
AND A SECOND BY BLOOM.
IS LEGAL -- ONE THE TERM ADDRESS
CLOSE AIR SUPPORT TAX.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION TO PASSED THE COMEDIAN
LOCAL GOVERNMENT STATE.
HI IF I GABRIELLE.
GABRIEL I GLORIA.
GLORIA I KILEY.
KILEY IDLY MONTH.
THE MONTH I MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE QUIRK SILVA.
I MOTIONS YOU. FIVE TWO FIVE OUR
WITH GERMAN.
BACK TO THANK YOU COLLEAGUES
WHEN WE NOW GO THROUGH -- ALL
THE ITEMS FROM THE TOP OF THE
ORDER -- JUST TO MAKE SURE WE
ADD ON ANYONE THAT WE NEED. TO
ONE WHICH IS CONSERVE
[inaudible]
HIS [inaudible]
I WOULD.
WE DON'T OKAY FILE ITEM ONE I
THINK EVERYONE HAS VOTED FILE
ITEM TO AB THREE NINETY THREE MS
AREA.
THE MISSING MEMBERS REMEMBER
LEMOND.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER IMAN I THE
MEASURE GETS OUT EIGHT ZERO
FOLLOWED WITH THREE AB FOUR FOUR
SIX CHOI -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GLORIA.
GLORIA I KILEY.
HIGHLY MON.
LIMóN I MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
NIGHT. TO SEE THAT GETS OUT
EIGHT ZERO FILE ITEM FOR AB SIX
SEVEN ONE FRIEDMAN.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA.
GLORIA I IMAN.
WITH ONE NINE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I TICKETS ARE EIGHT
ZERO FILE AND FIVE A. B.
[inaudible]
SEVEN TWENTY FOUR OKAY
YES.
THAT ITEM GETS OUT SIX ONE FILE
OF FALLEN SIX WAS PULLED FILE
ITEM SEVEN AB TWELVE SEVENTY
NINE BLOOM SEVEN MEMBER KILEY
[inaudible]
KILEY I P. [inaudible] FIVE SIX
TICKETS OUT SIX ONE FILE ITEM
EIGHT AB THIRTEEN NINETY NINE
ALSO BLOOM [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KILEY
[inaudible]
KILEY NO.
THAT I'M GETS OUT FIVE TO FILE
ITEM NINE AB FOURTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN CHEN [inaudible]
SEPTEMBER KILEY.
KILEY I THAT GETS OUT EIGHT ZERO
FILE ITEM TEN AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
THREE GRAYSON A SEVEN MEMBER
KILEY.
KILEY LEVINE THAT GETS OUT EIGHT
ZERO FILE ELEVEN A. B. FOURTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE WICKS SEPTEMBER
KILEY.
KILEY I SIMILARLY MON.
NOT IN.
AT ITEM GETS OUT.
SEVEN ZERO FILE ITEM TWELVE A.
B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN AND
THAT'S MINE.
THAT'S GETS OUT FIVE TO FILE
ITEM THIRTEEN A. B. FOURTEEN
NINETY SEVEN HOLDEN.
I HAVE NEVER KILEY.
KILEY I BUT I DON'T GETS OUT
EIGHT ZERO FILE AND FOURTEEN WAS
PULLED FILE ITEM FIFTEEN EIGHTY
FIFTEEN SEVENTY NINE GABRIEL.
I'M SEPARATE GLORIA.
GLORIA I MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN.
NINE THAT AND GETS OUT EIGHT
ZERO FILE ITEM SIXTEEN AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTEEN FRIEDMAN.
I SEPARATE GLORIA.
GLORIA I MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
I THAT AND GETS OUT.
SIX ONE AND FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN
I THINK EVERYONE HAS VOTED ON
THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR THIS
MEETING HAVE A GOOD.
TURN RECESSED SEE EVERYONE THE
WEEK AFTER.
THIS MEETING IS NOW ADJOURNED